[Music]
Bo
o
[Music]
p
a
[Music]
f
[Applause]
[Music]
n
[Applause]
[Music]
f
oh
[Music]
dwire welcome to gam spots launch Day
live Extravaganza for this little diddy
melig your Solid V
the phantom pain uh finally we can get
our hands and we can actually live
stream and broadcast and show off uh
this game which we reviewed and gave it
10 out of 10 gamespot's 10th ever 10 out
of 10 uh last week uh I think the video
review should be hitting the site in
just a second if you want to check that
out but if you want to sit with me and
experience the first few hours of melar
Solid 5 the Fantom pan then uh welcome
if you're watching on gamespot.com
you're watching on twitch.tv/ Gamespot
or if you're watching this on YouTube
gaming that's gaming. YouTube
uh.com Gamespot welcome to those in
America staying up late to those in
Europe uh up maybe a little bit early
let's get stuck in it says I'm logged
into the server which means Konami uh is
okay with us playing this video game I
guess so uh I haven't I I don't know I
haven't played any of melar Sol 5 yet
I'm a fan of the series I played a bunch
of grand zeros and I'm very much looking
forward to getting uh into this with you
guys uh as blindly as you guys are so I
keep my godamn outshut during all the uh
cutscene stuff and we'll try and stay
away from as much story spoilery uh
content as possible but obviously the
top of this game is probably going to be
pretty spoilery let's be honest it's
hideio kajima game and it's probably
kind of have a weird start on it God
damn it this my favorite part of doing
these live streams is
enjoying whatever loading animation they
have which should kick in in a second
the one thing I want to see more than
anything else is does it say uh kajima
Productions on the uh the opening
credits let's wait and
see here we
go there you go mday mday controls
unresponsive Tower do you
read [__] calms are
down
just another day and a war Without
End so an educated guest would be that
the start of this game is
uh is going to be reminiscent of the
initial teaser trailer we
saw Moby Dick
Studios but we'll see
did a David
[Music]
[Applause]
Bowie
[Music]
yo Tay can I get some more audio out
here thanks
[Music]
dude all right I am in control of
thisy
Baker spoke into his eyes I thought you
died alone
[Music]
not
me I never lost
control you know what you know what name
we all want to pop up
[Music]
[Applause]
here
come on say David hater David hater come
[Music]
on I'm trying to remember everything
that happens in the trailer at first
trailer I remember there was some sort
of psychomantis looking
[Music]
dude I think there was some sort of
image of Cypher there as
[Music]
[Applause]
well Union
Flag flaming space whale yep good point
team
toaster this looks
[Applause]
[Music]
good
yeah controls are pretty laborate as you
can
imagine
wow hey thanks for the flowers
appreciate it how's my arm
[Music]
doing
hey what's up good luck
[Music]
s b kicking
off a don't pass out now you idiot God
damn
it
V has come
to I guess that's what it
[Music]
means V has come
too holy [__] okay wow all right let's
get straight in hopefully it doesn't
want me to download anything else let's
just see there's any options just for
shits and giggles I might turn on the
uh um if I can if it lets me I'll turn
on subtitles so you guys can see
everything let's just go
on and I think that's all I need
subtitles on yep apply
please brightness seems okay I think for
the stream let me just kick it up a
little
bit for the sake of
twitch I know it gets a little bit dark
on there
so let's uh let's punch
it V has come too was like the slogan
that was used in a bunch of trailers uh
prior to the game's
release I guess maybe maybe other people
put two and two together but I hadn't
thought of coming two as in all right
I'll shut up
again prologue you all right this should
probably be the first 6 hour came
then can you hear
me are you having difficulty
speaking can you move your
head yes nod yes just nod am if you can
hear
me
how many times you want me to
nod look up
please I got
you very good thank
you how do you feel now fantastic can
you
speak what is your
name where when were you born can you
recall oh
really uh
okay sure this is a bit little bit weird
uh I'll go with my own
name January 5th I'm a Capricorn do I
need my full name or just Donny yeah
whatever you don't need my full name
also why you asking maybe for high
scores good now
then please try to relax there is plenty
of time I bet there's
not I need to tell you something please
listen and try not to
panic you've been in a coma for quite
some time yes yes I know you would like
to know how
long I'm afraid it's
been 9
years [__] I left my car parked double
parked down it's going to
beic couple of
thousand try not
toic you'll be all right okay sure begin
in offline
mode
this is all out of my control by the way
this uh this whole
segment I'm not quite sure what the
online stuff is apart from
the the PVP stuff in mother base but I
guess we'll find out
later hey oh flower girl thanks again
for that it's been one week since you
came to now let's try getting you out of
that bed thanks
Dad don't worry you've lost some
strength but we've been maintaining your
muscle mask through massages CPM therapy
and EMS appreciate
it what part were you massaging I need
to explain I had some weird dreams but
you must be
alive now last time he said that I had a
[__] panic attack and fell asleep for
a
week in an explosion
upon examination we discovered 108
foreign bodies embedded within it
Jesus in addition to shrapnel we also
found fragments 100 of human bone human
teeth
mine most of it was removed but some of
the fragments still
remain they are located
near your heart and in your
skull that explains the
trailers both the uh look at this thing
on his head the fragments are lodged
deep within your cerebral cortex and the
bandages we couldn't give you an MRI the
metal you see but even if we were to
extract it you would most likely suffer
a brain H yeah well don't do that then
I'll just look like a Halloween costume
for the rest of my life mental and
physical impairment are
unavailable however your current status
is not lifethreatening
but you'll never date again one more
thing all right is this my Johnson is a
weer
but you better look now best to
understand your situation oh [__] my arm
I know it's difficult but please look
down it's best to see with your own eyes
oh it's fine my arm's okay after all
thank God for
that oh
[__]
no try to calm down calm
down calm down it's going to be
okay yes yes calm down yes my God it
does sound like ke for Southerland
grunting though so
yes so I guess all that time in the
voice Booth paid
off uh if you've never played a me solid
game before and you're watching this
this is pretty much power for the course
so don't
worry expect likely a bit more of this
before the action
starts and then probably some more of
this again and then the credits will
roll five erors in and then the game
will start it's true this is pretty cool
though I'm really into this this is
great you should be dead but you're not
the wheels are in motion your enemies
are everywhere we must alter your
appearance
immediately otherwise I fear you won't
leave this place
alive it's a wide open world out there
so there's something we need to take
care of first
the J shock's doing a real good
heartbeat here
actually oh [__] hey what's
up I'm going to change your appearance
we have no other choice don't cut my
sweet beard look like
however do I get to choose do I get to
choose what I look
like this going to be like The Witcher
again where I asked the barber to cut my
hair oh what the what
really what are you kidding me you
straight up get to [__] just like
change your total face what the [__]
okay this is
weird uh wow
okay gee this is [__] crazy I'm like
totally I'm totally taking it back by
this are you kidding me I can I can make
solid Big Boss black that's [__] cool
can I be a
girl I guess what the hell is going
on oh this is [__] crazy uh I can't
pick classic so some people are asking
for classic are any of these look
like okay I got to go okay let's go two
them one by one cuz I want to make sure
that we're we're not you know there
could be someone hidden in here that's
like straight up old character face or
something who this is
crazy
um oh go there's a lot of faces to
choose from look at this [__] Jesus that
guy look at that guy he looks like he's
in The Witcher three Mike
Tyson [__] Goldberg with scarf
faces Asian Santa Claus this is great
this guy kind of looks like Chris
Hatfield that astronaut
dude that guy whoa all right that's all
of them I don't know guys I kind of feel
like I want to go
with one of the black dudes this is so
cool this is
crazy face tat
snake uh okay sorry if I'm taking my
while on this but this is literally
taking me a b
um I don't know maybe Mike Tyson snake
where's he going this
dude this guy looks like he'd [__]
someone
up that guy's pretty good all right I
think maybe Mike Tyson
snake
this is crazy what are you kidding
me oh my God
uh okay let's give him a nice bit of
hair eyebrow
type is this for the whole game or is
this just for this intro part oh I like
the most look at that now we're
talking or maybe this situ
I I like oh mutton
chops oh my God facial hair length three
obviously are you
serious I don't even know I don't even
know what's happening now this is
like this I'm so taking a back right now
uh
okay I don't know what to do I'm like I
don't know if I'm supposed to like do a
joke person or if I'm supposed
[Music]
to take the make wow wow I'm glad the
chat is freaking out as much as I am
because this is super
crazy
[Music]
uh
sure
let make a bit more softspoken jawline
nice nice
thick all right skin color
wow look at this this is
crazy
wrinkles full
wrinkles
there this doctor has
just done one what the f you are got to
be kidding
me oh my God
what
uh is this I [__]
tattooed
uh this is so strange I don't even know
what to think here yeah all
right
um okay I'm just going to get into the
game because I could spend forever doing
this oh I can't you know what I got to
get that that's just too
cool no actually it's kind of lame um we
said we go for Mike Tyson let's
let's how about
that Jesus Christ yeah bullets there you
go that's more like it some bullets
inside of his
face uh
okay okay I don't know what to [__]
think use this Avatar
sure [__]
hell
unexpected I am guessing that this isn't
big
boss wow doc you've really done a number
on
me
very good now let's remove this B uh if
you just joined us uh I've woken up your
face has healed Nic as somebody who
looked like big boss and I just changed
myself to be bandes were more for your
protection to hide you from those who
want yeah sure you're going to change me
back later as of today your name is Ahab
okay oh I'm Ahab oh [__] watch your back
your name your past
dude
okay so this yeah all right all
right I don't this is [__]
[Music]
crazy
yeah why' you show me
that this is you as you've lived until
this day what what the [__] going
on tomorrow it
becomes a
phantom oh Jesus
Christ what the
[__]
uh I'm still I'm I'm in control of
looking but I'm
not who the [__] is that not yet the
patient in the next bed on my
face of course get the [__] gun it
done oh [__]
[Music]
oh for [__]
sake is that
quiet whoa that looks like
quiet Jesus Christ
uh just throwing [__] at
her [__]
hell if game's like 4 minutes in already
I'm like what the
[__] I can hit right trigger to zoom in
and that's about
it what
the well she's not killing me so
presumably she wants to get me
alive oh Jesus
Christ
whoa what the
[__]
wait where' I got the arm
from okay have time to
go wait that's key for sett in what
happened to the
woman the woman I we gave her a light
she took the short way down who are you
do we have the same voice who am
I you're talking to
yourself been watching over you for 9
years
you can call me
ismel what the hell is going on well the
good news is here in the land of the
living bad news the world wants you
be on your feet Soldier the whole place
is coming down
okay [__] twin Snakes am I right get
the [__] you pick me
up okay yeah sure whatever
here wow nothing like a little digoxin
to get put you back in the
game come
on wait am I snake again what the [__]
is going
on am I Big Boss again well I don't even
know follow
me Drug's not
working
come
on we're getting out of here move
it all
right let's take the stairs
yeah sounds good I can barely walk on
flat
ground okay no other buttons are working
except for left
trigger doesn't matter where I look that
this is all
precount on help me out bro Jesus
Christ give me a
hand no put Ed come
on
this
way yeah we're playing on PlayStation 4
here my boy Ty rude is uh capturing this
on PC right now so that footage should
be up on Gamespot uh post
haste
go come
on this isn't going to work
we better take the elevator you at least
like you could just drag me along or
something for God's
sake you kidding me this guys like the
you are
useless I can see your butt
crack wonder if they pay had to pay for
sing more to get his butt
cracked oh my God so I'm confused
because if I made that Avatar and
neither of them
clearly are that Avatar because oh
God is that
psychomantis what the hell is
[Music]
that oh what the
[__] I love these games so
much something's
coming
what
so much for the bound oh
[__] oh
man
is this
C
okay
all right off we go again more crawling
Simulator
Jesus [__] should have stayed in
bed you can do this is this some
[__] gravity George Clooney stuff
going on right now butt crack butt
crack
you Tyler deran is that what's happening
here that's it come on stay
up in good let's
hurry yeah right there's a wheelchair
right there here we go here we
go
now he's got us here we
go more
helicopter hold up let's fix
this fix what oh [__] did he break his
arm oh
that sucks next time do it yourself I
think I think I just did do it myself
from the
enemy over
there wonderful dudes with
guns come
on uh if you're just joining us here on
Gamespot or twitch or YouTube uh this is
the first we're half an hour into met
Solid 5 the phantom
pan and I haven't a [__] clue what's
going on
already okay now we're talking actually
move around a
bit um that's that's
ishma ahead of me who apparently was in
the bed next to me I think
quiet was trying to kill me in the last
scene at one stage it asked me to make
an avatar for the game and I made a a
guy who looks like Mike Tyson but I
don't think either of us are
him what the [__] is going on wait
that's not
help me please wait where's my
buddy oh there he
is yeah I'm having a hard time believing
that guy actually
exists typical might go solid if I hit
right right stick in it
zooms think we all know what happens
here
beautiful this guy's doing a really
shitty job of looking underneath the bed
oh
God
oh my
God so I got tanks on their back let's
move presumably because of all the gas
they put in
here
Jes
Su what the
[__] I don't want to
die wait
what [__]
hell
what was that noise
[Laughter]
typical move move
move here over
here God you guys are
idiots
time to walk press the stance button to
stand
up don't get CAU did he just tell me to
press the stance button is that what he
just said oh my God all right so hitting
down there
is
here they come hurry all
right all right there you go dead
already what's the death screen look
like continue from check on me Ahab Ahab
I'm
back all right there you go I died the
first chance we even had a chance of
dying let me try that again resume time
to walk press the St Buton to stand up
stand SP to stand
up don't get caught in those search
lights
is that down button that is the center
of the touchpad right am I going
crazy apprach an ox an obstacle such as
a wall head on un hug the obstacle
conceed yourself okay maybe I should
have done
that all right I'm going to stay low I'm
going to stay low bro cuz this tutorial
did not work for me so I'm just going to
[__] air on the side of caution and
crawl my ass there you go all
right okay can we keep moving cuz that
guy's probably going to get
shot all
right L3 is Dash got
it uh why'd you
stop all
right
yaa
hey how's your day at the hospital
going would you [__] just run why did
you close the thing and then just stand
there like a bunch of Goobs come on go
go go that guy knows what's up
go wait do I go up or down oh I guess I
go
down so yeah okay touch the wall and
then you
can walk along
it hurry this way keep going keep
going
yeah I mean I could wait for you but
you're probably a fiction on my
imagination I'm going to keep
going
down turn back what oh
[__] this
way come on oh hey you know what I
remember the trailer guys I don't think
I want to go in
there what's happening out there
it's all right we'll be okay I can't see
what's
happening hey you guys ever heard of the
term fish in a you hear that in a no no
shooting fish in a barel no all right
don't worry about it then I'll stand
here I can see all your butt
cracks hey can't see what's up what is
that yeah safety's safety and numbers
exactly you hear them coming butt crack
that's not me looking at that that's the
camera yep
all please
please fuing
hell
okay all is this part of the tutorial is
that what's
happening
see I can't see oh there he is he's over
there oh [__] oh
[__] oh [__] oh
[__] okay okay
okay [__]
hell uh buddy you want to move from that
one oh that's really cool that I knew I
was
there
love that hand
movement oh [__] that's so well
done this is great this is really
good
yeah don't worry about me bro I'm doing
good I got my sweet
beard oh how the [__] did you not see
him all
right goopo in the chat is tense I am as
well I'm wiping the sweat off my Palms
here
anything
negative he came in here keep
looking what was that
noise yeah just maybe don't be standing
there maybe just like
yeah [__] are they come back in again I
can't move by the way just
FYI where' my bro go
all right I'm going with
you this way can they are they over
there no we're good okay we're
good we're sitting ducks blend in with
the bodies get down on your stomach
and didn't know fish in the B but he
knows Sitting Ducks all right d my face
is in your butt move oh [__] no
dice all right tip number one don't walk
too much to your your your buddy's
butt or it'll make you stand up
automatically God damn
it the one thing I'm liking about this
is at least this section the low times
are super fast super super
fast okay hold X to crouch got
it all right here we
go we're sitting ducks blend in with the
bodies get down on your stomach and
crawl oh will I'm just going to let you
go ahead of me a little bit
first like super slow crawl is that what
you're getting
at okay you want me to go alongside you
if you move we're done for play dead oh
[__]
like I'm not moving his head I really
wish he wasn't like so obviously
breathing like
this well it's good to know the quality
of guards and M your solid hasn't gone
up since the first
game you know these guys are really
checking if people are dead you think we
should just be sitting
here oh
[__]
what this happening why is that guy
holding up a [__] rocket launcher is
got to Rocket the body to make sure it's
dead thumbs up we kill them except these
two bodies which aren't as bloody as the
other one but presumably that means
they're more
dead
is he peeing himself he [__] is he's
peeing
himself game of the
year wait is everyone peeing themselves
what's going
on oh dude you [__]
moved
oh what the
[__]
Manus
okay I'm still holding down the x button
I'm so nervous
[Music]
who [__] makes these
windows grenade you [__]
yeah all right i' be I'd be running
right now Lads if I were
[Laughter]
you [__] pyrro
mantis oh the noise a great meter solid
noise right
there what the
[__]
Dam [__] hell I'm like rocking my
brains through like old Met Gala people
to try and figure out what the [__] is
going
on is
he
jeez
okay great all
right
okay yeah can we just get out of
here
ding dude you saw the part where he they
didn't kill with a [__] helicopter
right water my one weakness
no
oh Smoke from Mortal Kombat got it all
right sorry took me a
while well if this isn't a video game I
don't know what
is you better stop and treat that injury
sure wow okay it's like Far Cry 3 I just
hit triangle on he resets himself
serious injuries if you sustain a
serious injury you'll be unable to
perform certain actions such as climbing
over obstacles or getting on your horse
I'll be honest getting on my horse not
so much of a concern right
now keep moving keep moving man who pees
himself we'll have to take the stairs
down
God all right I can wait I can
wait
[__] hell all right who the hell was
that was that like the person I'm
reaching at is oh
[__] the game I'm least familiar with is
Snake Eater but that kind of looked like
vgan and I guess that would make more
sense TimeWise right for him to look
like he did
then like I don't know when this is set
exact [__] [__] [__]
[__]
all
right finish him off like they finished
off everyone he's probably peed
himself you want to give me a gun
maybe thank
you all
right
oh my
goodness hold down the aim button to aim
then press the attack button to got it
left triggle right trigger
right R1 switch cameras got
it let's reload
square and see how much like a modern
game this is circle got it
oh
sh I'm so sorry I'm so sorry I'm so
sorry butt crack dude I'm so sorry it's
just I haven't used a gun in 9 years
since that time I had radical racial
surgery that instantly wore off okay
sorry folks sorry folks really three
times in the tutorial is just too much
but look at those loading screens
they're so quick they're so quick and
that was pretty
funny all right we're go back
I'm like genuinely impressed by those
loading screens though that's like a
straight like six s second
turnaround [__] first person like
like your solid two
[__] there you
go eat
it all right left trick to flick over
or want to go [__] straight up mgs2
style my busted ass hand look at that
[__] he's able to reload his busted ass
hand no problem wasn't able to walk but
5 minutes ago now I'm reloading guns
with a twig for an
arm all
right can't get over the butt crack
I am so fascinated as to how this
resolves when we get into the proper
game this is
like kajima is so good at
this all
right
I'll run
interference if he says what was that
noise I'm going to lose my
mind oh
Jesus shoot him
dude
attack what else we
got
are [__] [__] [__] [__] [__] [__] [__]
[__] [__]
[__] oh well they know where I am now
your buddy's not coming to get
you hey it's taken
four little a fanky
fanky on 14 [__]
RS
see stay
down is that
it any
more oh I see
it better
gun
where the [__] did my buddy
go get the hell out of
here I guess
so
what
mantis
yep did that stra up
say his name on the
suit no it's in
[Applause]
[Music]
celic
oh great it's our old friend
again well it's been an hour since we
started and this has
been [__]
thrilling
h
oh you got to be kidding
me okay
[__]
[__] sure quick
dive
moving in go go
go is fan still in there or who I assume
is I guess I don't even know if that's
psycho Manus but I'm just putting two
and two together
here
oh he's going to turn on
them
[Applause]
Jesus
Oh my Jesus this is
ridiculous yeah get the [__] out
man
[Music]
uh
okay I think I'm probably more confused
than I was at the start if I being
completely
honest uh if you just joined us we
started at 9:00 this is meler Solid 5
the phantom p
uh we're in the
pr I can't imagine there's that much
left in
it I guess all there is left to see is a
flaming
whale
H get
in come on get up
man
the fire brigade
unlucky
oh Jesus
Christ oh
[__]
[Music]
you
I wish I wish I don't wish but if you
could see me that whole time my mouth
was just open like what the [__] is
going
on Okay
cyprus outskirts of [__]
zyau 1984 okay
okay so 84 would be 10 years after Peace
Walker that was in
74 and uh I guess 21 years before met
your
solid which was
2005 what the
[Music]
[__]
oh look who it is get on
I'm on your side sure you sound like
Troy Baker famed voice actor I'll go
with
you
H all right so that's AEL
[Music]
lot [__] is use this watch our backs
shoot it now what the [__] is going
on care SL to
reload all right or three with good
coming for you I got that
earlier slow
down reload a couple of rounds come on
[__] Ghost
Rider [__] is
he back from the dead huh yeah
exactly he didn't vulgan get killed in
Snake
Eater does that mean manmade of bees is
going to make a return as
well [__]
hell bro I'm running out of ammo here
you get him did you get
him we shook him
all
not so sure oh
[__] I mean should I use all my
ammo yeah that's vulgan look at the
[__]
electricity
that is a surprisingly resilient
horse
Bravo I have demoed and played done
gameplay of countless games throughout
my life and usually pretty okay about
like trying to add some sort of
commentary to what the [__] going on
but Jesus I was [__] flaming
whales code name chick rank there you go
folks code name
chick ah hits taken six no tactical
takedowns one head shot 74% accuracy I
think I was pretty bad with that shotgun
at the
end uh okay that was the prologue of
Meer Solid 5 uh the phantom pain but
we're not done here we're going to keep
on going
um check out my heroism yeah Fists in
the air I feel like Fists in the air
wearing black gloves in the 70s is
reminiscent of something else hiio
kajima but whatever uh score rating
800 uh exit
[Music]
results okay video games are alive and
well in 2015 everyone if you're staying
with me which I hope you
are uh we're going to keep going I don't
know how we get from Cypress to
Afghanistan I guess it's not
particularly
far other side of the
Mediterranean no S rank yeah sorry oh hi
mantis I guess you're not afraid of rain
like your
friend yeah that must be V come on
oh hide
coima story planing game design in case
the first hour of this game wasn't proof
enough that he has his dirty hands all
over this oh my God this is great this
is
great
okay are we one long horse r away then
ocelot my name's ocelot big boss you
know who I am the certain man gave me a
job to do two actually first was to get
you out of that hospital second was to
rescue the man
himself
what you
remember your partner 9 years ago Kazu
Miller Master Miller 9 years back your
private Army came under attack by Cipher
I remember you were considered dead
until today that is when Cipher found
you and it's not just them the whole
world wants you
dead you'll have to join up with Miller
build that private Army of yours one
more time it's your only
chance
doesn't talk much does he keep for
settling I mean I guess I could try and
kill Cypher I could wait until he's an
old man in a wheelchair but whatever
Afghanistan Afghanistan there you
go and we have to get there in 24 hours
what you can't keep up with world
affairs in a
coma four years ago the Soviets invaded
Afghanistan the Muslims are fighting
back with Western support Miller was
training mujahedin Rebels when he was
captured by the
Soviets the Red's 40th Army troop
strength somewhere around
100,000 Squad holding Miller set off
near the Pakistan border
yesterday now in 3 days they'll reach
the Soviet Garrison they'll be
interrogated for a few more days and
it's off to a loger or left to rot in a
ditch on Afghan
soil I gave him two
weeks the job didn't mean anything to
Miller he only took it on to keep you
safe well there's our
ride it's a wailing ship had a pretty
good deal on her once the IWC started
raising a stink now seven days to Port
cim another three over land so we won't
have much time once we're
there don't take too long getting used
to your new self hang
[Music]
on God this is
great okay so uh
I'm guessing this matches up with that
E3 trailer we saw last
year when acelot wanders into
Afghanistan and sets you on your
way I'm interested though it's said two
weeks for Miller I wonder if that's
going to be like if we're going to get
into some initial levels where we're
invading bases before they set us off in
the sort of open World part of it
chapter one
Revenge bye-bye
Cyprus into
Syria come on we go to Syria and take
out Isis that'd be
fun for
side o I like this ran the World in 80
Days [__] going
on down we
go
Yemen Arab Republic around the
coast down around
[Music]
man much better arm thank you
sir over to
Pakistan India to the right well maybe
not North to the Afghan
[Music]
border
yeah let me get my sick beats
on time for
[Music]
pass for some reason I've suddenly
felt excited about playing a new Red
Dead Redemption like this is going to
tickle that edge asan's briefing the
Mount of
fire music tape two
okay I wonder what those rewards are
based on based on uh my score in the
previous level
maybe uh this is the longest loading
screen we've had so far and it's not
that
long very very impressed by loading
screens although presumably in an open
world game you won't be dying quite as
often as
uh as usual I guess we'll see when once
a once a major map has been loaded how
long the loading screens
are man oh man how's the chat doing how
you doing I'm keeping an eye on Twitch
I'm keeping an eye on gam spot I Got
YouTube open as well I hope you're
enjoying the
show this is just I'm really yeaha is
under total Soviet control also
wondering what that character creator
thing maybe that's just my avatar in
online or something I don't know but
that was really
weird weather will clear shortly thanks
Siri stor
pass everyone's into
it h according to Sony PlayStation the
game should be available from 9:00
Pacific but there are some technical
issues occurring and some users may not
be able to download the game until
midnight Pacific which is Just sh 2
hours hours from now uh I do believe the
game has unlocked fully on Steam though
so if you are uh looking to pick this
bad boy up on PC you should be able to
do so uh right now fingers crossed uh
our boy tyroo here in GameSpot is
currently downloading and running it on
the highest possible settings and we're
going to get some gameplay of that up on
gamespot.com in the coming hours uh and
I'm going to be playing here over the
coming hours until I don't know let's
say 3:00 a.m. holy [__] that looks good
[Music]
okay after n years on
Ice solo infiltration of the Soviet main
Ground
Forces huh sweet eyewear ocelot gear
[__] Beats by
ocelot sweet shrapnel
brain
he really doesn't talk at all it's quite
weird kazer is being in oh that [__]
frame rate you are kidding me take out
your idid oh that's
amazing okay you see on the map that's
where they're keeping Miller only
problem is we don't know his exact
location finding it is your first
priority oh this is amazing this is so
exciting okay there's the map mother
base doesn't exist yet missions go ahead
and close the item I don't want to close
the [__] eyes I'm playing with my new
phone leave me alone for a second play
cassettes I'm over
here be this is a tiny piece of the map
oh man or should I say in
scope in scope don't say in scope
Village Straight
Ahead a little to the left to the
right over
there
a little to the left have you spotted
The Village no I haven't spotted The
Village all right that's the village oh
there it is all right you see something
through the binoculars and you need more
information just give me a call I'll
tell you anything I can about
it that's voo Village the voo C the
villagers fled the war and evacuated a
while back since then it's become a base
for the Soviets 4th Army a few days ago
Miller was taken through there on route
towards Dean dear you may be able to
pick up the trail there okay it's worth
a shot put a marker on it so you don't
lose track of where it
is mar now you won't have to worry about
getting lost along the way did I come
out a controller as well much left in
him I give him three days tops if we
fail and he dies we lose our chance of
Revenge okay sorry I'm just trying to
keep my eye on exactly what he's saying
but uh yeah this is [__] 60 I'm
pretty sure on PS4 this looks amazing
see what you can find out
first the Soviets have other outposts
not just the one you saw I'm sure they
do my friend Afghanistan is a big
place I expect you'll become quite
familiar with those binoculars as you
plan your next
move how and where you oh this is so
exciting well that's up to you from here
on out you're on your
own all
right hey do something cool with your
song
of those who live on the
battlefield that's why you have to
handle this Mission
yourself put those nine years behind you
and return is Big
Boss that's how cost we wanted uh I'll
be sending additional Intel by R pause
stay
sharp not one of Miller's bodyguards
survived and they were good all we found
on the scene with their corpses don't
worry I'll folting their corpses out of
here and I'm really good at my
fingers and you're his only hope of
getting them
back
casgar God that shrapnel is really
nasty now go let The Legend come back to
life
unnecessary getting off of horse oh my
God look at this [__] oh this is
preposterous oh he's gone
already
okay I am so [__] excited I feel this
is like this is like getting out of
Vault
101 that moment where you're just like
oh man look at this playground yeah this
is like straight up 60 frames a second
this is amazing this looks great smooth
as hell H I'm sure it's not coming
across in on the
stream oh my God all right let's play
with the
buttons all right what else came up
there uh tips tips I can cover quick
dive reflex mode effective range shots
on target serious injuries auto
aim all right and let the rest of them
come up let's just keep
going let me take out my Droid
again so here's the
village Intel radio a few days ago
Miller was taken through there on route
towards de dear got you the transport
log might still be around somewhere okay
what about there they've got Miller
locked up in that town but we don't know
his exact
location God look how far you can zoom
in holy [__] you can see so
much okay so I want to go over there get
the transport
log and then uh and then get my ass over
to where he is I want to check out these
cassette tapes first of all let's see
what the hell this is about
so
info he said I was in a British Military
Hospital that's give for doctor had a
Greek accent they hire locally easier to
trust them delli is also home to Greek
cyprio wow this is crazy okay what about
the Turks they haven't returned to the
South not yet the cypess all fair enough
I don't want to bore you guys with too
much of this if it's optional
what's this snake I wanted to ask you
about the Man on Fire great movie Denzel
Washington my man anything we can use
well he took off the moment the
sprinklers started up sprinklers the
fire system it's a little bit weird that
he didn't speak at all basically for
this start of the game but he's like
super chat here but whatever what else
we got
here got some sweet
music met your online trailer music oh
right at the Valkyries great bit of bit
of Vagner it's like Battlefield
Vietnam or some or
some some sweet some sweet Bowie I just
listen to it while
it's okay all
[Applause]
right Jesus
Christ all right triangles get off your
horse triangles get on your
horse this all controls really well I
just say I'm
not like
this this feels this play this feels
super
good let me uh let me get out my
binoculars
here able to move and not move with the
horse as
well all right I got to go up here and
get an eye on this uh Pace while I
listen to David [__]
Bowie
slow and
[Music]
horsey it's like everyone's first song
they learn on guitar almost at the enemy
outp viow Village the village is
crawling with enemy soldiers don't just
go waling in start with some Recon is
there anywhere that overlooks the
village up there but I don't want to
should I go right in the
back I guess yeah go down this
way for years and years I
[Music]
Ro I get R the back
here pretty forgiving the horse stuff
he's like basically wandering around
things I mean who knows this could end
up being like you know Vice City levels
of cool sound
trag [__] yeah Witcher three type of
medicinal plant bring it back to base
dude I'm in Afghanistan they have all
the medicinal
plants forget this
whole virtuous Mission [__] I'll
just I'll just own a opium
plant that's marking focus on a thread
and it'll be marked automatically gotcha
you can Mark enemies and vehicles by
zooming in with your binoculars or
camera once they're marked you'll also
see their positions on the
map all right let me Mark a bunch of
these
dudes before I get my ass in there I'm
going to try and stealth as much as this
is
[Music]
possible this is a metal gear game after
all
as this is basically the the base they
had in the uh various uh demos they were
showing
off I feel like I could get a better
angle from here what time of day is
it does it say it on
here toggle nav map oh wow look at that
you can just do that that so cool I can
switch to zoom here as well this is a
really good
interface
truck Intel a few days ago was through
rout toward de wow you can listen that
out while you're walking around as well
be around
somewhere what if what is my horse if I
hit how do I get my horse do I
[Applause]
just I don't want to leave my
[Music]
horse L2
no okay here we
go
oh easy
boy don't worry I won't kill anyone
until D Bowie stops
[Music]
singing
extraction arrived at another base oh
cool all right I'm not going to go any
further with this
[Music]
guy what was that one they
used
infiltration enemy
presence what bit dead okay here we
go pistol grenade I'm going to go with
this
slowly does
[Music]
it how do I
duck music's about to F out all right
here who else we got
here couple dudes in
there doesn't seem to be that many
people kind of has me a little bit
worried parabolic antenna there could be
Intel files of some kind in there I'll
get
them okay I need to get in there and get
the log book
I guess I don't have to I guess I could
probably just go up and try and extract
them but something tells me that
information is power in this video game
there should be a command post somewhere
see any buildings with tighter security
if there are Clues to Miller's
whereabouts I'll bet you can find them
in there L2 and
R2 cover attack r3's
Peak L2 and R2 there you go tranquilizer
Effectiveness tranquilizer rounds will
take longer to take effect depending on
you hit the target perform a head shot
to put them in sleep immediately don't
don't for don't worry I remember met
your solid
too God this is
great
there's no silencer on this guy is there
oh there is okay I might use it oh [__]
truck truck truck truck
truck where's he
going ooh I can do the old sneaky sneaky
get in the back of the truck that
truck's probably on its way to the base
isn't
it can I see that on my
map yeah I can there he
goes okay I guess it's not going to the
base or maybe it's
maybe it's taking the long
route okay
okay easy does it I got killed a lot at
the start I don't want to make a habit
of
it there one guy in the background I
didn't
tag
probably a bad idea but let's
try I what else on the
roofs
big combat
roll all right I'm going to go back
around I'm probably being a little bit
too careful Sun's down already it goes
without saying that darkness is good for
infiltration that's what I like your
vision will be affected just the same
keep your guard up or who knows when
you'll bump into an enemy
got it line
Insight all right let's take this do
that I'm guessing get behind him and hit
square
square holy
[__]
stay the [__] down don't leave bodies
out in the open find some place to drop
them out of okay not my best
work but we can remedy
that all right buddy we're going on
we're going on that little little walk
about here don't worry about
it Jesus [__] nailed it right
weapon limitations while carrying you
cannot use your primary weapon while
carrying an enemy soldier prisoner
figured as much speaking of which let's
reload this
guy don't know how much suppressors got
left on him not much it looks like
okay is this blood and gun going to be a
problem or we are we cool a blood and
guns in
Afghanistan
guess I want to get up here
right not sure if I want to do
that maybe I
do
is that you have arrived at your
destination all right where's my
Intel those materials are already
processed did I just F in that come in
handy sooner or later I think I did Why
not start Gathering oh [__] is he coming
up
here oh there's Intel Intel Intel get it
got it get
it
yeah scan that
[__] that's like more effective than any
scanner that was really like created 30
years later oh
[Music]
[__] the map has been
updated [__] [__] [__] [__]
[__]
stick your head
in oh my
God
okay okay that
guy's that guy's about as good as
that guards in like your solid
one
Feld resources
Fon
Bon where' that guy go over there all
right okie dokie uh all right what the
[__] did that tell me
about I was so nervous there I didn't
even chance to see what the bloody told
me let me
regroup all right what did it say what
did it say what did it say here's all
the different map modes we got aerial
photograph
mode we
[Music]
got this map
version you can either set it the way
you're facing or uh I guess natural
North and what else we got here
log there's a lot of [__] here going on
in the mother M mother base map info
updated anything there no all
right did I get some more information
about Miller's location
then in
here he's in there somewhere
okay that's
that's where they
holding
okay all right don't worry I will Fon a
goat if I see a
goat any have like Fast getting my horse
back that would be a really handy thing
to know about video game hint how to get
your [__] horse
back a whatever I'll just go get him
planning to walk the whole Wilderness on
foot nope use your horse
yep oh here we go thanks video
game it's up to you whether to slip by
enemies or take them down just remember
that any situation can change fast
familiarize yourself with your weapons
and items while you can whistle de be
able to switch between them quickly to
meet any
threat y all right that's a little bit
you got to hold or one and then you got
to select the
direction and
then uh hit or in so that's a little bit
much but whatever we'll get
it
okay oh [__] look at that change hiding
position can hide on that side you can
hide on that side
oh [__] am I just going to run someone
here okay keep going keep
going
whoa I'm heading the right
way this isn't that this similar to Mad
Max actually EXT distraction arrived at
mother
base sweet got all that fuel at mother
base anytime you need advice just give
me a call thanks AEL lot old buddy old
pal tap the call button L1 to use the
radio and receive advice from your
comrades in addition if you use the
radio while pointing her bitar specific
object you can receive explanation
tactics pertaining to that item
so I can hit elb whenever I
want tap it hiding on allows you to stay
out of sight even while on the move it's
effective for avoiding enemy guard posts
and long range reconnaissance
patrols hiding on Horseback press the
stance button X while you're on D horse
to cling the alide decide you hide on
the pens all right can I get through
here while hiding on my
dorse
[__] that's a pretty
big oh you know you know what we got to
try you have to try if it's going to say
if it's going to tell me now to hide on
dehorse then I should probably just hide
on
dehorse this game is so dumb all right
swap
sides can I hard save at any stage
that's a good question actually I know
all right
clip clop clip clop don't mind me I'm
just a horse just horsing around enemy
guard post watch
yourself going for a
walk all
right that worked surprisingly
well
okay halfway
there uh hi if you just joined us by the
way uh you're watching the first couple
of hours so far the first hour and 42
minutes of miger Solid 5 the phantom
pain h on Gamespot on twitch.tv Gamespot
or on gaming. youtube.com Gamespot uh
I'm d d and I'm about to ften the [__]
out of these
flowers bye-bye
they've already arrived at base uh this
is my friend
deor I'm guessing d stands for diamond
or Diamond Dogs or something like that
uh and I'm on the way to get uh Cas
Miller we did the prologue which was
very
strange had some psycho Manus in it we
think had some vulgan in it we think
revolver ocelots been in a couple of
times um and this game looks and feels
really good like the horse controlling
is is spot on the shooting feels real
good like just like gr zero is dead
obviously the horse stuff is all new oh
[__] we are fing you come here
you what do I do to got full come here
come here come here come here come here
[__] do I have to tranquilize you or
something
[__] don't make it shoot you
again [__]
come back
here I shot him fair and square yes did
he fall
down oh [__] did I kill it can I not Fon
sheep yet God damn it stupid
tutorials this game is [__] I'll
take back that game of ear I said
earlier there's a very good chance it
doesn't let you f in stuff that early
or maybe I did kill him is this just a
straight up suppressed
pistol maybe it is all right I don't
know maybe I just murdered that thing I
don't
know all right let's get some
uh let's get some height so I
can scope this place out as it
were too
high
maybe a
bit oh that's a big
base Big Boss big base good
fit we got a
turret got another
turret got this lamp prick and this
stupid lamp God this feels like I'm
playing a any number of first person PC
games from
2003 like I project IGI or something
um that looks like where theyd be hiding
that's where it
says marker placed place my marker over
there doesn't look like there looks like
there might be some access from the back
but I'm not sure if I can get up there
in the first place presumably not if
they built a base
here everyone's walking over there like
they've seen something I don't know
what's
that there's a pigeon which for some
reason has got three dots over it like I
should night is that Sam
Fisher all right let's uh guess we going
to horse our way over there under this
beautiful
moonlight all right apologies if I'm not
looking at the chat all too much at the
moment uh learning the in intricacies of
this game one day
taking up a bit of my attention for the
moment check yourid for his location I
hope to hell he's all right he's not
your average
Cent it says he's in
there in that big
building extraction arrived at mother
base hooray I F in all those pedals and
I went back to mother
base spare no expense
USU go a little bit faster
okay oh [__] there's some people coming
over here I see
them all right let me get off and see
what the [__] going on I saw some guys
running over towards
us I kind of want to scan them more than
anything
else okay they're not running they
walking
okie
dokie yeah Shaka likes that project IGI
reference deep Cuts here on gamespot.com
at 11:00 p.m. at night here in San
Francisco oh
[__] come on keep going
goodness uh yes for those in the YouTube
chat wondering the PC version is already
out at least it should be um everything
should have unlocked about uh just under
two hours ago on Steam and on
Playstation uh son are reporting that
there is some sort of uh technical
problems that some users are occurring
on the PlayStation 4 so PSN might not
unlock U Meer Solid 4 or sorry five the
Phantom pan for them until midnight
which would be another hour and 12
minutes um but it's worth checking out
uh on Steam everything should be okie
dokie we've got oh [__] [__] [__] [__]
[__] they saw me [__] [__] [__] keep
going uh we got Ty rude here at
gamespot.com uh capturing on PC right
now I believe on ultra settings so we'll
have some gameplay of that up uh fingers
crossed pretty soon we're also going to
have Graphics comparisons up on the site
uh pretty soon and our review our video
review rather of migar Solid 5 should be
live on spot now as well um we gave it a
10 out of 10 last week obviously that
was only the written component for some
God known reason kenami decided that we
weren't allowed Show gameplay of the
game so we couldn't actually put
together a video review until uh until
the game went live and all these
restrictions went down but
uh yeah it should all be
good they're all asleep those two D two
dudes are
asleep all right what happened to those
other guys are they I guess I can check
on this thing
thing gun placement okay they kept
walking this is a super user friendly
iPad all right can I shoot out
lights
nope maybe I've just not oh there you
go hey
this there's a guy over there I haven't
scanned him though
Let's see we can get in
here another
guy guy
sleeping
[__] while he's
there okay that was the guy who was
there a second ago so that actually
worked out for
us these are some diligent troops for
whatever the time of the night time this
is 3: in the morning or
something I F all this [__] nope all
right what about
this okay unnecessary but
sure yeah it just straight up flens them
like through the ceiling as well there's
just like no care for realism at
all
whatever I guess what am I talking about
realism after the first hour of this
game H the one thing I will say that's
real is the tension this
is this is really something
else there's a wolf of some
kind
[Music]
oh
[__] who the [__] saw
me there's someone in that building oh I
see him I see him
now
[__] I'll wait for him to come out to
see his buddy and then try and attack
him [__] I maybe I should flank
[__] maybe I should pant on
them
[__] great two of
them it might all be going to [__] in a
second [__] go
down oh my God that was close
Okay do I got to move all these
bodies is Miller in that building right
there okay that's good at least I'm
close hide all these [__] throw that
guy over
there get the next
one there that guy over there
come
on oh [__] you guys better stay
asleep come on come on come
on should I just kill
them uh for those who don't know what
fing is sorry uh the Bon recovery system
is something used in uh in I guess this
and and peace walker uh where you
basically tie a
balloon [__] should I just kill these
guys I'm not sure if they're going to
wake up or not I'm not sure what rule
convention this game is using okay I'm
just going to keep going uh where you
basically you strap a massive um like
balloon to something and it shoots it
into the air and then a helicopter
collects it and that's like oh [__]
that's the building BX that's where the
holding yeah probably shouldn't have
just jumped through the window like that
but whatever you have arrived at your
destination yeah so what I'm doing is
I'm I'm basically recovering all that
stuff via
helicopter uh which I'm sure they will
explain later on but if you've seen
enough videos about uh met your solid
you you'll know what I'm talking about
no more use for me
huh guys it's
me I'm here to get you out I'm kefir
Southerland now
don't ask questions your
eyes no
it's it's just bright at
all poor Master
[Music]
Miller for th for those of you who
aren't too familiar with that's pretty
cool he's got his glasses on
there that's
awesome H Master Miller was uh if you
remember M Gear Solid one was the the
dude who was telling all of our plants
and [__] who ended up being well it
wasn't really him in in meler solid one
and it was Liquid liquid snake
but you SEC the target great I'll send
the chopper to get you out I'll F in
these resources you can check the
location on your
idroid mission info has been updated
okay I just got to get there shouldn't
be too hard
right I guess I wish I'd scanned more of
the base so I knew where everyone was
you look well [__] there's a
guy
[__] slowed you down one bit get the
[__] down so heavy anymore all right
let's get out of here that was
cool can I at least jump over this no
really
come on man he's able to reload guns
with a twig for an arm he
can [__] can I duck a little I guess I
can magic words
boss I've been waiting 9 years to hear
him kept you waiting huh come on save
for all time
sake uh can I stick him on my
horse
hey what's up
boy of course I can this game is pretty
rad what's
that sorry shiny thing on the ground
this isad diamonds L that's a rough
diamond good fine it'll fetch a high
price
awesome this is crazy we've done the
prologue this basically feels like some
sort of like this is like white Orchard
or something this is the the tutorial
area for the this
is at L this game
stand I wonder if you ever come back
here again or if this is just like a
small little tutorial
land sorry for the rough ride
bro Ahab do you read me this is
pquad there's a gas covering the LZ we
can't
land back
what well thanks for alerting everyone
to our position
yes it's
them what the
[__] what the
[__]
boss watch out it's the skulls don't let
them find us extraction arrived whatever
that mist is it's all around you we
can't see through it I'm changing the RV
so it's outside the Mist get over there
the chopper will be waiting okay do I
need to do I need to hit triangle is
that what that's trying to tell me or
should I just like I don't want to get
the horse I'll be completely honest I'm
happy on the
horse I'm happy on the horse I'm staying
on the horse I'm sorry video game I'm
staying on the horse how the [__] do I
get out of
here if I go down there I
can take that little road I
guess
[__]
I go down here and
around you know what
actually I need to scan those guys so I
can I can see where they
are
okay let's [__] do
it no they're going to kill me every
time what
the what the
fuckos to I'm running don't worry about
it
holy
[__] how close are these [__] Jesus
Christ what the
hell got to dodge
him [__] sheep over there doesn't
stand a
chance
l
I'm going to hide on the side of my
horse two [__] can't get
me [__]
run L this horse is almost is just
wrecked I don't see a Horse Stamina
gauge but it did
stop what the
hell is that them gone are they
gone the miss is cleared and it looks
like they're
gone I better I'm not sure if this going
to work this time with you sitting on
the back of the horse but we'll
try that was really cool I don't know
what the [__] that was about but it was
really cool those things that's the unit
that attacked us before they came at us
real fast in the same kind of mist our
men survivors from 9 years ago were
wiped out in minutes I don't know what
they want but it's them no
mistake the skulls I'm guessing
skullface has something to do with
it which uh seems to be the main
antagonist from Grand zeros this
isru the L froming request immediate
remal oh is it me I'm I the obstruction
is it
deor
you get in
there
okay are we getting out of here or is it
just
him all
right guess I can man this turret if I
want
buting eat
[Laughter]
[__] extraction arrived at mother base
okay first trophy of the day I'm
doubting I'm did very good yeah I'm not
surprised could rank B I think I got two
out of the
four uh missions on offer there I'm
wondering if we can go back and replay
these from any sort of
central menu uh but yeah there we are
we're two hours in now uh on Metar Solid
5 the phantom pain 44 Mission or minutes
for that mission and I'm guessing we're
getting back to mother base now maybe
maybe not got that GMP balance so the
GMP is the uh currency which goes
towards look at all that heroism um
which goes towards you being able to
purchase I guess those points from uh oh
really it rolls credits every time
crazy uh that lets you purchase um
things for the the PVP element of this
game in between
uh this is
crazy awful I want some more music give
me some more music I want more Bowie
that was the best part of the
game we headed for
the that's where our new home is now
sweet say is
beautiful
hey
that was some operation we had huh 9
years
ago carving out our own
world making our own
future and they took it
away Ty are you playing this on PC at
the
moment oh you did is it going up on the
side I mean I'm
soon all right Ty Root's just come in
he's been playing on PC apparently looks
amazing looks really good unfuck
unbelievable one of the best looking
games it runs really well on PS4 it runs
like I'm running at 2K you're running it
on 2K 1440p 60 FR second holy [__] all
right we got a 1440p 60 FPS uh running
on a running our machine what machine is
that what craft cards in there kind
dirty M we find is
it oh fair enough the're 3 980s in
there on SLI so I guess it would work
diamond yeah that's Prett cool though uh
so that gam play is going to hit up on
Gamespot uh in the next couple of hours
I guess some of our former uh looks
great here on PS4 you guys can't see it
on the stream but this is running at
60 I'm able to control the camera and
stuff uh but that's pretty cool good
good to know update from TY rud so I'll
be going up on
gamespot.com in the next little
while
yeah
man oh man hey yes YouTube chat loving
that Master race can I do 4K I don't
know
Ty Ty come back I'll ask him if you have
any questions about the PC uh version H
shout him
man this is a flashback to the end of
grand
zeros
the grand zeros for PS4 on a 60 I kind
of remember
actually uh the grand zero also looked
spectacular on PC but apparently it
looks even better now
help poor Chico exactly as I
[Applause]
planned
boom remember that cuz they put a bomb
in
her
give my regards to your boss when you
get
home
skullface all
right yeah YouTube making a good point
releasing Mad Max LS like this was a
maybe not the best idea um we gave Mad
Max a 6 out of 10 on gam spot I gave it
a surprisingly
High 8.4 they're kind of higher than the
median but and that's what reviews are
all about
here yeah bit of a shame though two open
world games where you're going around a
desert I can feel my leg same day and my
arm even my
fingers oh is his arm gone the body I've
lost the comrades I've
lost won't stop hurting it's like a
phantom pain they're all still there
it's like a phantom pain say it you feel
it too don't you I'm the one who got
caught up with Cypher a group above
Nations even the
US and I was the parasite below feating
off Zero's
power it's like I I can't get over the
fact that it's a little bit weird that
he's not talking and I'm Afghanistan I
think it's because they didn't have
enough money to pakey for Southerland
cuz it's so strange it's likeing
everything in its path all those tapes
you can listen to him talking and he's
like not talking in these like normal
conversations seems a little bit strange
who knows though maybe a bit early to
judge that
boss I'm going to make him give back our
past take back everything that we've
lost and I won't
rest until we
do pushing mother
base dude be careful come on it's a
[__] open the helicopter for God's
sake our new mother base hell yeah new
mother base let's do it how long it'll
take but I'll make it bigger better than
before [__] yeah
go what should I do there you
go
tell
me tell me like you used
to paint me like one of your French
girls okay so weird so I guess every
chapter it like straight up opens like a
an episode of a TV show or
whatever episode two Dum and dogs this
is chapter 2 episode two then I
guess God damn uh When Ty comes in here
next I'll ask him about the resolution
apologies he's just disappeared into a
room room to capture more hot PC footage
for uh
gamespot.com things have changed
boss we pulling money recruits just to
combat
cyer rubbing our noses in bloody
Battlefield dirt all for
Revenge the world calls for wet work and
we
no greater good no just
cause
cause Cipher sent us to
hell but we're going even deeper I
know I'm already a
demon that is not my kind of place
anyway that's more like a bit of
chitchat as many talks it's really like
evocative it works he's the voice oh
jeez his [__] legs gone as well I
don't even
notice Dogs of War for nine whole
years that ends today
Jesus now you're not sleeping and we're
not junkyard
hounds we're Diamond
Dogs
let them
talk we can Crush Cipher boss and you
can build the army that can do it I sure
can there's one thing
C this isn't about the past we're
fighting for the
future
all right are we going to get into a
bunch more tutorials
now learn how to run weather
base oh my goodness yo Ty Ty Root's here
we're going to have a quick little
update about the PC I want a quick
update you want a quick I want to see
does death the f it's turned off right
yeah there is no depth of field depth of
field you want to have a look at some of
the display options yeah
sure looks good on PC then looks amazing
this is everything the only thing I
changed was I stuck on subtitle from
there wait no go get out of display is
there a graphics gra okay cool okay
that's all there is uh I see your PC
sorry we can't bring it up here 4K is
yes we can do it it can do 4K yeah I
haven't tested we got our textures
High looks good you got around three
3840 by 2160 at the moment that's 4K
that's 4 oh yeah you got it all up I was
just showing you the um if you want to
read out those things if you want sure
I'm going to I'm going to test to see
how well it runs right now cool get that
footage uh yeah for those who want to
know on PC uh the various um graphical
tweaks you can do Fe sync frame rate
auto you can set that down I guess as
well do you know what the frame rate
settings are can you
knock or free okay it's either 30 you
can lock the frame rate at 30 or have it
on auto uh motion blur depth of field
model detail textures texture filtering
Shadows lighting postprocessing effects
ambient occlusion and volumetric clouds
uh which uh seems to be all of them
which actually maybe not as many as a
lot of PC games but probably as good as
you're going to get out of kenami uh and
yeah we're getting 4K uh footage up
there um up on Gamespot post haste he's
got it running at 60 on 2K right now and
I think he's going to test it out all
right this game looks [__] good on
PS4 I will say that as well I want to
look at get some of this
hot [__] Big Boss face up here see
how good he
looks like I said uh this is running at
uh this base belongs to you now make
diamonds the deserves to all right first
things first everything needs to be pink
we need to make good of their talents
Miller asked me to lay that out for
you
sweet thanks for the Satchel start
bringing people in use this Fon it's a
Fulton recovery device [__]
yeah when you're in the field use it to
extract any soldiers or prisoners you
want back here or sheep or goats
persuade them to join the ranks of
diamond dos go on test it out on the
staff here anyone you want okay put him
to sleep you have a tranquilizer gun
don't you I thought I had a tranqu
you're
going sorry dude you're going to mother
base now appr
[Laughter]
andt extraction arrived at can only and
recover someone if they're not resisting
it there is bodies either they don't
make great recruits member you just
extracted will be assigned to the team
best his ability for yourself open your
ey nah he seems okay I'm sorry you can
let go pick up your gun and get out of
here Select Staff management from the
mother base menu oh my God so that staff
member was placed on the R&D team the
R&D team is in charge of developing all
kinds of weapons and items that will
support you on missions take a look at
the development list select weapons
items under the development
heading
[Music]
weapons
items dude what's wrong go back to the
mother base menu oh sorry select weapons
items under the development got it
please spe that's the R&D team's
development list see the item called
cardboard box see much use to me but
Miller was adamant that you'd want it on
the list the last word in infiltration
technology or so he said in any case we
don't have the manpower to develop it
just yet we need more staff on the team
go extract a few more
people no problem put the idroid away
for a moment you also Fon extract
individuals you've knocked out why don't
you try knocking someone out with CQC
next show them how it's done box try
throwing them it's the best way to knock
someone out
instantly I mean I could throw
them tilt l and hit R2 oh that's when I
did that stupid thing
right tilt L and press the sequen C
button or two to quickly thrown an
opponent and knock them all
right
boom excellent box I'll filter him back
to my base which he's already on because
tutorials so the filter recovery system
if you don't know is actually a real
piece of technology but thing I should
they obviously don't use it for [__]
like that always be successful if the
person is injured the shock of it could
kill them and if the weather's
unfavorable well they could end up going
missing what is up with that shadow of
success by approaching the person you
want to extract you want to be sure you
can get them out best carry them to the
chopper instead all right extract the
next staff member full and Recovery
success rate depends on
weather and make sure they're not sick
got
it
uh what you want me to do I get this guy
as
well B in his
ass bam that's probably a bit I
shouldn't do that that's that's probably
hurting them too much see you
dude more people on the R&D Team level
has gone should be able to develop card
great I'll open my idroid in a second I
want to choke this [__] out first and
then send him to my base which he's
already on yeah so the the way the
Fulton Works in real life is the balloon
goes much much much much much much much
higher and then there's this like
trailing arm from a from an
airplane that basically Scoops it up and
these are from for larger packages in
this crazy kind of rope [__] that makes
it workd items under the development he
it's weird like when you see Aires
refueling in the air kind of weird just
beware development reques FS GMP GMP
baby we don't end up in the red no
problem I'll use that GMP to do some PVP
as
well 1 yeah good go for it now does it
unlock it straight away it does finished
that's
cool uh yeah give me a carboard box
supply drop you can have the support
unit Supply you with weapons and items
you've developed think of it as your
personal Delivery Service Supply drop
complete here it
comes it's going to drop straight down
or
what oh there it is that's
cool oh does that land exactly where I
put it it does H apparently you can also
knock people out with those supply drops
and there it is
not sure what it's good for buter said
you know what to do oh I know what to do
it don't worry about that my friend the
STA members you exted were all placed on
the r team but that was Miller's
decision if you think they belong
somewhere free to move
them I'm sorry I don't know who you're
talking to I'm in this
box sure I love my or if you're still in
the mood for knocking guys on their
asses you can stay around here a while
give them in some practice just come pay
me a
visit let's practice your CQ Begin by
grabbing
Tada so dumb Jesus
Christ all right for real how do I get
in a [__] box oh my
God game changer do
this I'm just using my
binoculars oh he is not impressed with
my box
work this is so [__] stupid I love
it great wait is that how is that how
you deploy
it let's do this boss uh I'm going to go
with
this and go carbo box it just drops out
of the [__]
Sky sure I don't know I don't know what
I was
expecting
okay it's going to take a little bit
while to get used to anyway what's
up restrain
youate knock out K him scratch that last
one for I won't SL this Thro don't
worry knock him the [__]
out go on and
extract it's we're just wasting Fons I
get
it what about this guy can I at least
interrogate
him tell me where the base is tell me
where his base is repated to knock him
out he'll stay unconscious for longer
than if you throw him this guy just
looking at me killing look this guy tell
me how to do it boss tell me how to do
it all right how do I choose which one
oh there you
go where the where your
friend weird all
right want me Chu this guy out as
well isn't like you snake try one more
time I'll grab this
guy thank you boss thank you
boss what's the matter give it another
try okay what do you asking me de but R
press secrety but without moving you can
unleash Max fight oh punches great I
just punch this
guy nope that's not what I meant there
you go thanks for that boss
than thank you
boss thanks for that
boss thanks for that boss don't worry
I'm just a carboard
box ha punch you in the face thanks for
that
boss this game is so dumb
I love
it extract the STA M extract him back to
the base oh my God whoa extraction
failed oh sorry apparently you can't
extract people if they're wait great the
the game goes for realism when the
[__] Fon sure
whatever it's like all the same noises
from Meo one as well when you like
people fall over and
stuff
this is
amazing
extraction everyone gets a fon
extraction arrived at M base all
right marker placed marker extraction
arrived at the
base yo how do I call the chopper
bro yo bro how I call the chopper you
want me to kick more of these guys asses
or
what there you
go everyone gets a
fullon great all right don't worry I'll
go do missions when all this stuff is
done and dusted
extraction arrived at mother
base extraction arrived at mother base
mother base
menu wonder if I can do any more
development now that those guys are
there specify
project I've already got that one can't
upgrade them yet all right there's
nothing else to do
there nothing else in the development
one staff
management night crocodile sadistic
Mastiff and Brass Armadillo are you
[__] kidding
me
they've all got like Solid Snake style
names that's just beautiful it's
beautiful thing helicopter get your ass
in here please select a landing Zone how
about that big Landing Zone Landing Zone
this is arriving L got I'm right at the
lia
unbelievable this isad on station at LC
Dusty
face there we go presumably onto the
next
mission see you AEL
lotud really does look beautiful
if you're just joining us on
gamespot.com on YouTube uh gaming.
youtube.com/ Gamespot or on twitch.tv/
Gamespot uh we're about two and a half
hours into Metal Gear Solid 5 with a
Fant and
pain H you've missed quite a lot of
spoilery stuff in fact if you just
popped in there this is probably not a
bad time to be doing it uh the first two
hours are has been added well the first
two and a half hours are pretty tutorial
based the first hour or so was a a
prologue the second hour was a sort of a
Sandbox Mission which will be I guess
emblematic of what happens as you're
invading different bases total play P
222 just about um and I imagine what's
happening now is that we're going to get
shot into the uh more open world aspect
of the
game just having a guess uh yep they
roll the credits every time you finish
it chapter or a mission which is a
little bit weird but sure I'll get used
to it h it looks great on
PS4 UH 60 frames a
second looks great you know for a PS4
game I'm getting all the cassette tapes
most of them are information from ocelot
and other people uh sort of a lot of
them are
um uh further information for the for
the rest of the
game why you running down the what's
going on Eric you okay just presetting
have you seen it on PS4 Eric Tay every
time I hear you say credits I like to
come and stop oh just in case fair
enough have you seen it R on PC uh yeah
yeah look much better than on
PlayStation
4 just go on just say it I guess I just
don't care enough personally I think
that it looks good like it looks good
like it's just for that person who wants
like this looks really good to me too so
PS4 game it's right up there haven't
been back long but I prepared a list of
misss say you can't go back so open your
eyes
yeah well once you go PC you can never
go back that's the problem all right
here we go open up my
Droid what missions you got for
me please select a mission I've taken
the job offers Diamond Dogs has received
and made a list of those I want you to
consider which ones you accept is your
call the objectives of the missions I've
added are prisoner rescue facility
sabotage and high value Target
elimination probably all a walk in the
park for you but they should help you
get back on your feet I put the mission
details on a cassette tape refer to it
if you decide to accept the mission
we'll receive GMP for completing
missions and extracting soldiers and
prisoners will boost our ranks building
up mother base is the first step to
achieving our goal cool if that means w
work so be it we're going to have to get
our hands dirty I hope you rest it up
because we're not stopping not until the
pain is gone the future of Diamond Dogs
is in your hands we're counting on you
boss no problem C okay so here we are
mission list uh we can go back and
replay the older missions and they've
now got extra tasks complete the mission
without triggering reflex mode um we can
do the uh getting Miller Mission Again H
there's I guess I got two of the six
when I did it the first time extract the
commander from the other Barracks
complete the mission without being
discovered by the skulls okay I should
have done a better job there extracted
the transport truck TR that's cool um
secure the rough diamonds hidden in the
span keep uh the Diamond Dogs one I did
all that that was basically a tutorial
and here we are on I guess mission
number three a Heroes way or we can go
to this one or we can go to this one uh
let's listen to the types farming
villages in southern vahan have been
subjected to a strategic bombing
campaign the past several weeks the
damage is spreading it's part of the
Soviet scorched Earth operation aimed at
wiping out the
the target this time is the commander of
a spetznas Detachment he's been key to
the operation's success people say this
guy's responsible for annihilating the
muja atasi Lan the fighters overnight
he's a tough detail all don't
underestimate him the order from my
client in the west is to shoot on site
they want him out of the picture for
good sorry boss this one's purely
business wet work a hit on a commanding
officer of the Soviet milit military
nothing personal we're only doing this
because it gets us one step closer to
our
goal money's money okay so I'm wondering
if the tapes give you any additional
information that the text briefings do
uh they don't eliminate the spe nut
attachment Commander secretly involved
in the scorched Earth operation in
Afghanistan the Target and his Recon
unit have occupied yada yada y y y and
next one is destroy a Soviet comm's
equipment and prevent reinforcements
being sent between outposts extract the
engineer tried to effect from the Soviet
base campaign base camp and is now being
held at wacks Barracks okay so this area
doesn't seem particularly big is this
the same one I was in before
with
here sh yes it is okay so this one's on
in a different sort of map this one's in
the same one that I was in area I was in
with Miller's extraction and this one's
a little bit more North uh let's see if
I can zoom out a bit and see how big I
have no idea if this is all of the afas
Afghan map or
not um and I'm pretty sure well we know
that this isn't the only area that's in
the game either so it looks relatively
big for what
we're certainly much much bigger than
Grand zeros uh I'm going to go for the
first one Mission just to get into it
okay I can pick the
lumaz danger low danger low let's go for
this one looks like it's a little bit
higher and uh can maybe give me a better
uh oh Jesus a better uh advantage point
or vantage point when I start okay
select
buddy buddy dehorse I I'm assuming quiet
is another one of those but all I've got
right now is dehorse
equipment [__] normal apparently
nothing normal about this game but
sure select vehicle none I don't know
deor is kind of a vehicle select
character
snake what
okay I can't pick the black guy I made
at the start
though
standard I think I do like the tiger
stripe head option currently haven't
unlocked any head options can't wait to
find out what they are equipment primary
weapon
default yep both
those do I have anything else I can put
in there
nope uh
tools got my Fon I got my cardboard box
already nvgs and a cigar which is used I
believe for making time go fast uh yeah
so we have nothing else to really choose
from here at the start so let's just get
[__] right into it ASAP o that's cool
I can pick my arrival time what time is
it right
now does it say h let's go for the
morning
Sunrise not
Sunset all right this is weird he copc
corn King in the chat this is uh big
boss it's not Solid Snake this is too
early for that [__] I believe we're is
it 1984 1985 it's 1984 I believe so that
is 21 years before
the uh events of metal gear
solid uh so or way before uh Mr Mr solid
snake's
time ocelot the guy you saw there in the
last part is Revolver Ocelot who is the
one of the main antagonists in me
solid one through four
really like it'll be ashamed to waste
him but I'll leave the method up to you
no worries boss make your way to [__] K
and eliminate the
target okay this is interesting
so we're against the Russians in this
Mission but like clearly the skulls and
whoever exr and all that [__] is is
going to be the main antagonist in this
game so it's interesting I guess these
these missions are just you never know
like maybe the first three missions here
are just more like further little
tutorial iing to get
us accustomed to the the world and the
missions what I'm actually wondering is
if I'm able to swap missions while I'm
doing missions like right now could I
just
go into another one from here like you
know presumably I'm able to actually
walk around these other areas so what
what is there to stop me
uh I can ask
for I can that's cool I can call in
different buddies if I want so
presumably
quiet get the air support and can call
an air support if I get my ass handed to
me any more
music more of a music person ooh no
still got the manold the world and a
bunch of
uh Vagner and kajima stuff all right
here we are again back with my boy deor
oh what am I doing what am I
doing sorry I've just spent the past two
months playing The Witcher 3 wild Hunt
so I know what up we can use compounds
from Plants to make
or poison for so I guess I'm not fing
those I don't know I don't think I am on
yourid to see whiches we need o my plant
list then go find them if you get the
chance it'll keep the staff happy too if
I get plants it'll keep the staff happy
encyclopedia
Geral Rarity common oh [__] this is
great okay got it these are all the
plants I need these are all the animals
I need
need all right you know what this this
Mission can this Mission can wait we've
got some animals on I want to fed me a
[__]
goat all
right so the last mission told us
anything we need to get to a high
vantage
point to uh scope out the base I'm
actually getting really close to it
already so I need to back the [__] off a
bit I
think yeah if you're watching
on YouTube do gaming.
youtube.com/ Gamespot make sure you hit
that add
button got a bunch of streams here on
gamespot.com if you're watching on
Twitch feel free to follow
us and if you're watching on Gamespot
how you doing
Buddies
they got the gang spot Community uh what
else we got
here Intel hit L1 ask what's going on I
heard once that some indigenous in
Canada and Alaska deify the common raven
is a
totem look at that one I think I need
that I think that's why it's doing
that um not much else any
other not really many people here at
all the guy in here somewhere presumably
in this area because this is where all
the all the protection is
focused doesn't seem like it's that hard
to get in there so let's just make our
eyeses in
there Square to make dehorse
go a little bit faster at the your
should be somewhere in that Outpost
don't
forg detail with him keep your guard
up we'll
do it really does run fantastically
well someone who plays a lot of uh games
on
PS4 I am excited to see what it looks
like on PC as
well all right where are we looking
at I like how it's not as much of a
gimme as say Far Cry when you're
reconning like you do actually need to
find these guys for them to come
up wonder how specific their Intel stuff
is I did Intel on this for
instance plenty of Great Vines there
they're not bearing fruit but they'll
still provide good cover wow it's
actually pretty
specific boss intelligence work is all
about observation and gathering
information start by using your
binoculars to get a grasp of your
surroundings you know for a well guarded
base they don't really have any at word
raing
posts oh
[__]
okay so I could have chosen to coming
here at night
time uh which would
obviously uh change my tactics a little
bit uh I can also use
this magic
cigar which will make time go
faster and I guess I can stop using it
by just stop using it like
that and I just set my ass here for
something like seven
hours um and uh it actually has changed
some of the guards positions so the
other thing is that the
guards work on shifts so at different
times of day they will be doing
different things have different
focuses so you can also use that to your
advantage as well it's kind
of it's going to be hard to tell in
these early missions just how important
some of that stuff is because they're
always going to be like right now I
think they're going to be sort of
allowing you to [__] up and allowing you
to wander in and shoot your way if you
want to in the same way Grand zeros did
like honestly there's not that many
people in this base already so you can
tell that they're sort of giving you a
little bit of U leeway but uh it's going
to be interesting I think later on in
the game just how difficult that stuff
gets and from Reading Peter's review on
gspot.com
[__] H it certainly seems that like at
some of the more difficult levels later
on the game when you're forced to repeat
them that will require you to to be a
bit more
careful
[__] that him take a good look at their
so we can ID the target I think I just
killed him I think I ided him with my
[__]
bullet did I just do it
I think I might have just shot that dude
in the face I did
it
[Music]
great We're The Kids In
America this is so weird I love this
[__] normal music
playing take that have already been
processed it may not be much but we can
use some straight away if you bring them
back to
base okay process material fan Post
building guard poost and other locations
are a lower volume than unprocessed Ser
fing containers but they can be
extracted within a full recover device
so I am actually fing when I'm doing
that which is kind of weird but it's
weird that they wouldn't let you FL in
something that was underneath some
awning but they will let you fall oh
[__] this guy's coming up this guy's
coming
up okay I'm going to try and knock this
guy out with my uh where my
fists [__] ninja stuff
[Music]
style whoa where are you
going all right you can go up there if
you
want I'm going to Flo in some of this
can I take that
tape I really want that tape I really
want to listen to that
song I guess
not all right 6 in the afternoon or 6 in
the evening
[Music]
so I don't know what the
other requirements of this Mission are
they're
all like it's just asking me to xil
right now so I'm not sure if you don't
unlock those
until until you oh
[__] H either until you've completed the
mission or until
you've like run into them during your
time playing the
game I can't really
where the kids in America all right I'm
going to I don't think that guy's
looking over here so I'm going to set
shortly this time this this ended up
getting timed pretty well
actually I just don't know if I've
scanned enough of this area to see if
there's anyone else on the way
out actually I should probably check
where the LZ is first of all where is it
marker marker
removed there there's
dorse all right I guess I can check that
when I'm
at what was that I almost picked
something up oh tape I love you recorded
in the toilet great our first poo
joke of this met your solid
stream
I'm hoping as the sun goes down it's
getting less and less
visible get my ass out of here the guard
that was on top of that is no longer
there we might be still inside here
maybe
not might some might be some equipment
in here I need there as
well not there okay all right I want to
listen to
this dumb poop
thing exfiltrate The Hot Zone is all I
need to
do sorry it's taking a little bit
of a little bit of work to try and get
used to this this uh menu cassette
tapes Afghan
today where's the oh [__] that guy see
me
[__] great hey dude you want to come
work with me a mother
base is that going to
work sure it is
okay maybe I should vult in some more
people he's coming too Roger
that great oh my
goodness all right sorry I go back to my
[__] 3210 here missions cassette
tapes Christmas Eve 1979 cool just some
the Soviet Union rolled into Afghanistan
news bills Muslims have revolted against
the Soviet friendly regime established
the year before the Dr forces could no
longer contain it themselves so the
Soviets to
intervene oh government was
[Music]
[Applause]
powerless
great there you
go that's a dude [__]
himself dud taking
shits
okima alive and well in Myer solid five
all right I'm going to try and extract
one or two more of these jerks before I
get out of the Hot
Zone that blue light the last time I saw
one was blue lights it was one of those
skull guys so sorry if I'm being a
little bit a little bit sensitive to
it see if there's anyone else inside
here I also need to F in a goat let's be
honest there's the only reason any of
you are watching this stream is
to see some [__] goats get
vened it's definitely an incentive to
keep wandering around oh
[__] I guess they're just up here I keep
missing them when they're up
here
I can see his crotch that should be
enough come on SC SC
Gan you know what maybe I can just shoot
his head
then come on fall fall
fall all right you're still worth
filing up we
go and if you're not aware if you're
watching the stream and you've never
played a Mel Gear Solid game before um
there is a recurring character in this
series
who is often made a fool of and in meler
Solid 4 mostly he is known for having a
problem with his
bowels and if you are a fan of melar
solid and you've forgotten he is the guy
who marries Merill at the end of meler
Solid
4 who is the redhaired lady for meler
solid
1 and if none of this makes any sense to
you whatsoever don't worry about
it something tells me it doesn't really
matter okay get the [__] down rolling
while prone and running a weapon you can
tilt I'm guessing they mean like
so combat roll I do that in first person
as
well sure
can uh yeah like any M solid game it's
uh it's going to take you a little while
to get used to the idiosyncrasies of its
um of its control system
but all in all it actually controls
pretty normally extraction arrived at M
base in comparison to other games in the
series anyway but then if you
played Grand zeros then you're you know
what the story is here I'm going to see
if this guy doesn't turn
around so all that stuff I got has
extracted I'm wondering if it's going to
let
me
bam sorry excuse me I wondering if it's
going to let me pick a different Mission
now that I've just uh completed that
one no still wants me out of the uh out
of the Red Zone I guess I'm still in the
red zone so for that I'll hit L1 and
call
dehorse get on this [__] and
Trot our way out of here and if anyone
tries to see
me tries to spot me I'll do my little my
little
trick oh here's some
sand so yeah the weather as well uh
apparently
is completely
Dynamic whoa this is a [__] Sandstorm
I have can I use my nvgs here
maybe not
really doesn't make everything look rad
though
Jesus ooh ooh I can use it to kill this
guy while I'm here can you see me oh
yeah it definitely definitely helps it
definitely helps look at all these
[__] I'm going to kill all these
[__]
[__] that's what's
up
[Music]
H I'll fult on your ass in a
second once I gotten your boy oh
[__] guard post
captured
sweet see dude he just fell off the
[__] he just fell off the ladder and
I got him it's
great dude extraction failed extraction
failed
what about that guy is he okay you got
to extract him I
did I hope do you guys get him they told
me not to extract people When Storms
were on
but what can I say oh I can take this
really just [__] fting
everything oh it's too
heavy [__] all right maybe I have to
upgrade my Fon or something same with
this
thing you you going to not want to
go damn it failed I would got five Fons
left so I need to need to be
careful fixed weapon onl such as gun
placements mortars 910 cannons can be
captured after developing the cargo Fon
recovery device captured in placements
can be placed on mother base to help
defend base facilities also any surplus
weapons stocked out resources can be
sold off for [__] good to know
all
right look at that 0% should have seen
that
beforehand what else we
got so that guy might not have uh might
not have made it because he died on the
way because he died because he fell off
the the ladder I'm not sure what the
what the deal is there I did say I
captured this gun on placement though
which is pretty
cool just by virtue of the fact that I
killed everyone I guess uh and I've
completed that that mission no I'm still
in the Red Zone all right sorry taking
my sweet [__] time
here here we
go and there we
go now one of the cool things I liked
was that when I'm here you can like you
can just put it in the corner and just
Potter
along which is pretty
handy extraction arrived at M Base Great
the other dude arriv
it wasn't a complete bus hey boss you SE
many
animals yes I see many animals in the
field wild anies can be captured
directly by putting them asleep with
tranquilizer guns in the case of small
to mediumsized animals or Fon recovering
them in the case of large animals uh you
can also capture small to midsize
Animals by placing the capture cage
support weapon uh this support unit will
then automatically take captured animals
into protection I don't have that yet we
have something over there what the [__]
are you
complete no no no don't finish the
mission I'm going to capture those
[__] animals God damn it video game
God damn it mission complete at least
you made it out in one
piece code name check rank C terrible
absolutely
terrible what are you going to do we're
on a live stream I want to show as much
of this game as possible hello by the
way we're almost reading mid we're
almost reached midnight this is the end
of was that episode three of chapter 2
of Metal Gear S at five the Fant of pain
it's still weird that they run credits
every single time it's good that khima
Productions is still in the game
konami's last ever video
game ooh support helicopter Armament can
now be
deployed equipment for dehorse getting
used to being in the field again sure am
having Choppers and horse at your
disposal is indispensable for operating
in the wild Afghanistan I've got ahead
and arrange for you to be able to
develop and customized Weaponry for
support CH thanks bro and you can also
develop new equipment for deor if you
like use your ID Droid to start
development as
needed uh Allan the great one um I am
playing this on
PS4 uh we are currently capturing
footage for it on PC in a 60 frames a
second 4K which will hopefully be on uh
on gspot.com pretty soon this guy's
Estonian [__] you doing in Afghanistan
my friend I guess Russ whatever Diplomat
okay who else did I get I got dizzy
centipede midnight husky stubborn
buzzard and vile Viper I love this [__]
dizzy centipede though really that's
just that is great you win H that's cool
though so I guess the the higher skill
Soldier you
collect uh the the the more they're
worthwhile up oh is comprised of
problems we need you to resolve
objectives to be completed and
information gained from the soldiers and
prisoners you've extracted these aren't
missions per se but if you can take care
of them when you're free I'd appreciate
it no
problem more importantly I'm going to
Fon these [__]
animals 90%
chance
bye-bye coyote
nice greetings from Kuwait how you doing
Kuwait good morning and we're
broadcasting live from Gamespot
headquarters in San Francisco California
it's just just approaching midnight here
uh on gamespot.com on uh gaming.
youtube.com Gamespot and of course on
twitch.tv/ Gamespot as well and I just
ften my ass two coyotes God knows what
they're going to do all right can you
show any forward operation base footage
H you know what I think we'll try the
fob stuff once I've done maybe one more
Mission Let's uh what I actually think
is probably the case is that they're not
going to allow me to do that stuff until
I've completed these three missions but
we can always we can always give it a go
uh staff
management we got two more dudes pancing
wabby dire crocodile [__] so dumb uh
support unit no one in the brri at the
moment I don't know why that happens
actually
here's the whole
staff there's Kia ones and then there's
the I guess the ogs
here let's go into
development body equipment please
specify a project battle dress needed
for dehorse reinforc a bullet
bulletproof
Ceramics um I need a higher level of R&D
to unlock that
sadly uh what else we got helicopter
armaments ctif project
general purpose tactical helicopter
prototype for Next Generation
helicopter it's uniquely equipped with a
Fulton recovery arm I wonder if that's
the thing that's going to allow me to
pick up some of those uh some of those
armaments then speaker heavy duty
outboard lead speaker the sound
broadcast device developed to raise
friendly unit morale as a form of
psychological warfare against the enemy
its effectivess actual combat is yet
unclear that's amazing does that mean I
can play [__] music from the
helicopter because I already have some
Vagner on my uh on my little [__] pit
boy here so maybe that'll be worth it
um oh I kind of want to go with that one
it's 2,000 20,000 I've got enough for
that let's do that
Sher got a speaker Sher I got a speaker
on my [__] helicopter uh what about
you oh I already own you that's all
right uh get more better damage on my
Gatling
gun already got that
equipped I guess then you can just
upgrade your God this this I'm not sure
if the menu is particularly good here
but there's a lot going
on weapons and items already got the
carboard box most important thing in the
game this is
all various forms
of look God look at that look at the top
so the top is where
I'm going into the different classes
submachine guns assault rifles shies
grenade launchers sniper rifle machine
gun launcher Shields throwing weapons
apparently a magazine is a throwing
weapon uh placed weapons so we got some
different forms of sentex and whatnot
items this is where my cardboard box is
um I have a lot of reasons why I can't
get this support unit level R&D and
biological material I don't have enough
of then we've got tools
uniforms could get this all of drab
supply drop sure why the [__] not please
select a drop point actually no I don't
want to do that please specify a project
God there's a lot going on okay but you
guys are watching on stream you probably
don't want to watch it have a look at
uh menus the whole time I want to check
out these side offs though this is
something that Miller just said extract
interpreter Russian extract highly
skilled
Soldier all right let's uh which one am
I closer to this guy highly skilled
Soldier marker
placed let go find this guy be fun to do
a little side off what are cassette
tapes that I pick up any more sweet
music NOP still I got my Vagner there
and my recording of somebody taking a
[__] because because video games all
right off we go deor I still haven't
figured out where I can find out what
the time is time TW oh it's down in the
bottom right
2319 and off we
go holy clap there's a lot of guns
you're right William
Scout you're completely correct H thank
you so much everyone for uh joining
tonight it's obviously super late I just
got back from PX yesterday I barely
slept over the weekend but when met gal
5 comes out and you're asked to do a
live stream you answer the [__] call
this game is really good fun uh I'm
enjoying it a lot uh if for context I
guess I'm a fan of open World Games big
fan of The Witcher 3 wild Hunt big fan
of Fallout stuff like that I'm also a
meler solid fan but I wouldn't call
myself a super fan I completed the first
game uh second game long time ago never
completed Snake Eater but I got about
halfway through recently um and I did
about half of mear Solid 4 as
well and then got if I'm completely
honest [__] over the
story but I'm really enjoying this a lot
uh playing on PS4 at the moment it looks
absolutely
fantastic for a PS4 game I I will say if
you're a PC
player uh apparently it looks incredible
on the PC uh Grand zero is De Grand zero
has performed great on
PC and we're currently capturing some
footage we're putting it up on
gamespot.com real soon of running on
Ultra 4K 60 frames a second and
apparently it looks spectacular
hopefully I won't see any of it tonight
so it won't slurry my my uh image of
this but uh thank you so much for
everyone for hanging out so far tonight
on YouTube on Twitch and of course on
Gamespot as well I'm looking at all the
chats uh as much as I can but I sure you
can appreciate this is a pretty Hands-On
game and especially as I've not actually
played any before tonight at least I'm
getting used to it and I spot some
[__] animals is that a sheep sheep
confirmed someone's getting
Fon where we at where we at I see your
buddy there as well I saw your buddy
where is he there you
go I hear Fox but I don't care about
them FYI FYI what recording 4K
30 probably he's recording 4K 30 yeah
cuz 60 won't run that smooth 60 won't
run that smooth already on a [__] on
what hases he got 3
980s oh man tell him to get that 60 get
him get 60 in that 2K
then got to get that 60
man don't worry about 4K 30 [__] doesn't
even once it goes through YouTube it
doesn't even matter if it's
4K bye-bye
sheepy sorry that was ER T popping in to
uh give us an update on the PC capture
that's going
on I know I shouldn't count sheep I I'll
end up falling asleep UH 60 that guy
looks way too high for me to be
approaching from this angle let's see
what the story is is he up there
[__] all
right let's check out my sweet
iPad
I guess that's why it's a tough Mission
I guess that's why it's a special
[Music]
Mission I guess can I okay let's see if
this is if he if this is like
roach yo
deor no he actually comes over doesn't
just [__] appear from mystically from
behind
you here we go whoa
who thanks for this for us Danny no
problem thank you for tuning in I
appreciate it it's uh it's good to be in
a position to be able to do this uh we
obviously had Early Access to this game
we've had it in the office for about two
weeks we weren't able to show it until
the Embargo broke at 9:00 p.m. tonight
but because obviously we had the retail
disc and we could just [__] get it in
and we had it slightly before some
people although of course there were
midnight launches in the UK so bunch of
my buddies in England and Scotland were
already uh talking about installing it
when we were getting this all set
up I got to figure out how to get up on
top of this uh this outcrop of rocks so
I can get this dude that's up
here it's one of these things you kind
of get from playing the game for a while
as you figure out the limits on how you
can jump and stuff
so maybe it's up
here I'm guessing they put them up here
because it was going to be a a test
of dexterity
here oh maybe I'm on maybe I'm on the
right level
already let's see where he
is why is the screen so dark it's called
night time my friend oh sorry that's
exactly what gun man G man
said that's the
target okay how do we do this I mean
there's the right way and then there's
the Box
way
throwing
weapons hang grenades and other throwing
weapons can be tossed in an upward Arc
to hit enemies hiding behind cover hold
the ready button L2 to show the weapons
predicted Arc okay that's pretty good I
mean throwing weapons from a grenade
from a box sounds like about the most
stupid thing you can possibly
do
okay oh
god oh [__] there's another dude
there
I mean I should probably throw the
grenade
right extraction arrived at mother
base oh [__] why did I do that I'm
supposed to capture him wasn't
I oh that was too funny that was worth
it that was worth it totally worth it
100% worth it can I fult in this guy's
dead body
back oh that's great that's
great [__]
throw you have arrived at your
destination I'm here where is he where's
the guy I was supposed to
extract oh God all right maybe I'll
marker placed maybe I'll extract this
one
sorry had to be done oh [__] he's no
good he's no Ed to us
now busted ass gamy leg God damn it all
right marker marker removed okay let's
see if there's any fast travel happening
here doesn't look like it but I guess I
can call in my
chopper for a pickup please select a
landing Zone pick up I don't know can
you pick me up there probably not right
probably over here right the one I do on
the
road all right try here nope all
right how
about
here how about [__]
anywhere how about down
there
b back here here
here I guess there's probably too much
Rock here how bad
that whole Sandy area I was in
previously oh [__] you then it's worse
than calling an Uber all right where's
dbag dog
at or de horse yo
D okay so next mission slide Mission or
not to slide mission that was the
question I mean I should probably get
The
Interpreter I did Kill the other
one what direction we going in D
sth
oh can take a hit it's not too
bad and just so you know
for C know it's 2:00 a.m. in the morning
in the game so this is probably as dark
as it's getting
unless you count when sandstorms happen
and whatnot maybe some clouds blow in
but with a open Skies this is about as
dark as we
are bit of moonlight filming it all
up burn snake I really need to go to
sleep or I will never make it to the
store pick it up in the morning what
time is it where you're
at Wonder pass that by there is
intermittent saving happening as well on
the top right you can see it sort of uh
popping
in let me make sure it's not too dark
for you guys on the
stream yeah it's a little bit too dark
maybe tends to happen especially on
Twitch might might give it a little bit
of a
boost let me just
check yeah it's a little bit in the dark
side it's not as dark on here so let me
let me crank up the gamma a little bit
for you
[Music]
guys it's got its own menu I
lovely all right that might be too
bright let's give it a go and see what
happens it's pretty bright for me
now make sure I'm going the right
direction yeah yeah I guess I could have
gone down that way but I know that it's
not too bad this way
so yeah probably a lot probably darker
when it's cloudy
but know haven't we haven't seen much in
the way of weather since the stream
kicked in obviously the first two hours
are pretty
guided this is kind of like the only
time we're really starting to get into
like real Dynamic weather that was that
Sandstorm that happened that was pretty
dark
not too bad right now
though all right since these guys are on
the way I might uh might take the m is
that the oh no that's where I was
before all right time to Fon some
dudes
one
two
three yeah I should probably not have my
grenade equipped
I try and get one of these guys to come
out here using the uh The
Lure Noy Noy yes William stad I'm
playing on PlayStation 4 right
[Music]
now he just clanks his uh his wrist
together
uh-oh y yo dehorse I didn't mean I meant
to Clank my wrist you go away [__]
you're ruining my cover
dehorse gu need to be closer for that to
work let's
reload might be a bit too far to get two
of them let's give it a go worst thing
happens some chaos
occurs [__] you
duck
go Bo captured all right it ain't that
hard to get get these dudes oh no more
Fon my Ed Fultons God damn
it can I get them to drop in more
Fultons subject on board leave the rest
to us Mission supply drop ammo SL Fon
please select a drop point there
supplies
requested oh I should have dropped it on
him all right next time next time I'm
doing
it
next time I do it I'll get them to uh
drop it right on top of
them they coming
in supply drop complete all right
where's it
coming it's a little bit cloudy all
right so it's another sandstorm coming
in so hopefully this [__] doesn't get
lost that would be terrible
timing big boss for Smash Bros DLC amen
my
friend all right it's
down here's all our
stuff Fon recovery device resupplied is
some
resupplied can't see anything though so
I'm I just stick on my mvgs oh yeah here
we are yeah it does make a big
difference actually you can't see a
[__]
thing I'm going to fil ften these guys
out of here oh 30%
really oh yeah Sandstorm probably
shouldn't be doing this [__] Darude
you to exct him I'll wait until darude's
finished the last one didn't last that
long I was still stuck in the middle of
it when I was doing it I guess I could
always just stick him on the back of
deor come over
here
30% I was lucky to get that guy out of
here wait we finished we done all right
cool don't about
bro you'll wake up in a much better
place less sand
anyway I can't wait to get back to
mother base to see what the [__] is
going on with those two coyotes and the
two sheep hopefully they haven't eaten
each other he's coming too Roger that no
problem extract serious Clan I bought
the physical copy for PC but I still
have to download mostly from Steam as
DLC just downloading the link yeah
that's true the uh PC version is 9
megabytes when you buy
it if you buy the CD the the physical
copy it's a 9 megabyte DVD which has the
steam downloader or installer I don't
even think it comes I think you still
have to stick in the
uh the code
which is like it's bad but it's not it's
not that dissimilar to the way PC games
have been distributed for about six
years in that most only have like very
base elements of the game like less than
a gigabyte worth of information like I
mean when you down when you get a DVD of
any game it's only a DVD's worth of
information and when's the last PC game
you bought that was a DVD's worth of
information so like you know you got a
game like World of
Warcraft like even the [__] that they
have on that is is a tiny amount of what
the actual f file size of the game is
and that goes across everything like
things like Wolfenstein or or anything
like it's it's especially egregious in
this case because it's 9 megabytes of a
game that's whatever like I think it's
28 gig or something um so that's pretty
bad but like it's it's kind of part and
partial of how you buy PC games now if
you get physical copies
um and the thing is like because that's
the case then for many years you
purchasing physical copies of PC games
hasn't meant anything in relation to
your rights as a user in terms of DRM
because you're you're basically just
downloading the the game digitally
you're just
you're the means to you getting that
digital version have just changed
slightly so apparently I can use these
guys to hop in the back to trucks and
transport from place to place which is a
A Very Metal Gear one
uh
mechanic all right let's get off this
thing I hope you're having a good time
wherever you're at thanks for much for
hanging
out I'm streaming off the uh west coast
of
America I like filing people it's why I
keep getting stuck but actually you know
what I don't want to bore you guys with
me just filling up my base so let me get
over to the that get over to that spot
and hopefully I can extract this
scientist or this interpreter without
without using a grenade like the last
guy
which I'm deeply deeply sorry about to
his to his
family all right let's go up
here guess the one thing I'm wondering
is does any of this stuff get syy at
all you know open world games can cut
both ways you think of something like
Shadow morar it was fun experience but
like ultimately you were kind of
treading the same Common Ground over and
over again uh one of the great things
about The Witcher 3 wild Hunt was the
fact that it was so
varied I never really felt like you were
just doing the same thing over and over
again the missions were varied the
environments were varied the people you
met characters were varied combat
itself once you sort of learned
everything there wasn't really that much
evolving but it was sort of difficult
enough that it kept you engaged
uh so far in this I've actually found
extracting people
and and taking guys out to be not very
difficult at
all oh
no up this way
um or maybe that's to be expected with
just those little
grunts going to hide my
horse what I'm liking so far is the
variety of
different
I guess ways into different places so
far I've been doing the same tactics of
largely just scoping places out getting
in sneaking in
and doing the old metal gear sneaking
Mission but uh obviously there's lots of
other ways around it did I hear a coyote
or
something I need to capture every animal
in this
game no resale opportunity is a bugger
yeah that is
true I mean that'll be the worst part of
the brick and mortar store is closing up
is that the secondhand Market disappears
I used to work in a GameStop before I
worked at Game Spot uh for many a year I
worked in a bunch of different video
game
retailers and that was the best thing
found out there's an English speaking
Soldier somewhere in the region he's a
language specialist okay that's cool his
role is to translate information related
to the West into Russian if we can get
him to join us we'll have the upper hand
Info Wars info wars are
happening
that's our boy there I
think so that's cool so I obviously had
this Mission triggered because I wanted
to do this but when I wandered into the
area it um gave me a little
reminder enemy change shifts according
to time of day one tactic is to wait for
guards to change shifts at the beginning
or end of the day and slip through the
resulting gaps in the PO security but
that goes for the enemy as well
beautiful beauti changes in the morning
too watch yourself no worries
dude all right see where we're at
here I spent I spent oh wow last night
last night with your girlfriend with
your
girlfriend
that's really
good this gu's having none of
it okay looks like there's only two
three of them obviously now the sun's
come up I'm a little bit more
visible that Soviet soldier in the Green
Beret speaking English must be a
language you just [__] told me with
him on our side we'd be capable of R
interpretation support try and extract
him okay so there's no car here so
there's no chance of them those guys
leaving so I just need to isolate these
three I
guess oh I was a little bit too close
for
comfort so the thing I'm trying to
struggle with a little bit is I'm not
sure if there's anything stopping me
from just running in here all guns
blazing and taking these [__] out
which is kind
of cuz we're in the middle of nowhere I
get it and it's an early mission but I'm
hoping that's kind of not emblematic of
the rest of the experience H this guy
here is going to eat it though I got
it do
that this guy hopefully will go ahead
and check
it good man
[__] I might take out his buddy first
actually
you know what oh
[__] has you seen the other
guy knocking the [__]
out don't worry about me by I'm just a
[__] cardboard
box
come on let me lure
him come over
here
surprise
[__] Jes if you neutralize an
enemy you can then extract this game is
dumb this game is we should be able to
convince him to join
us I got our boy right here I got the
important one right
here subject on board leave the rest to
us
boom see I got this guy without uh
without killing him with a grenade as
well completed sweet extraction arrived
any goodies in here for me unit function
added boss that language specialist you
extracted has been very Cooperative ho
says he's always dreamed of living a
free life like folks in the west what
are the odds huh I've gone ahead and
placed him in the support unit his job
is Russian
interpretation now you'll know what
Soviet soldiers are saying interrogate
them should give you an edge in the
mission okay that's pretty cool I guess
now I'm able to I wonder if I can
literally understand what they're saying
all the time but being able to
interrogate them is going to be great
yeah I wonder I wonder if that means
like all the
Russians oops I wonder if that means all
of them are uh
are just basically speaking English
now crazy all right next
mission let's get to
the the biggies none of the side ones
are working anymore or done anymore this
one here looks pretty
close destroy the comm's equipment
Mission accepted the map has been
updated easy peasy lemon squeezy it's
right around the corner yo deor is he
going to come the whole way down here
wow this is like the complete opposite
of roach ooh pedals thank
you run run run run run
jump I'll never get you never get S of
that can you go to mother base please uh
yeah would you guys like me to head back
there I can
probably do it let me blow up this
equipment first I'll blow up this equip
and then we'll head back to mother base
and see what the goddamn hell is going
on
there
once I'm [__] ghost riding my whip
here exraction arrived at mother base
swap
over level six look at all that
materials okay this isn't too
far I think you're basically okay going
on the roads as long as you're not
getting in the way of the transport
trucks so the one thing I've not done is
like been found by a bunch of uh people
oh [__] what was that a little dingo or
something get
off look at this thing fult in that
[__]
thing
a hi
buddy I think he had a wiener did he
have a
winner Roger that we'll pick him up
extraction arrived at M wild animal pup
X1
report Sly Osprey and thunder
Badger good to
know what's this
thing give a hug to Portugal how you
doing Anna Olivera thank you for joining
us I think I just hacked the
Planet episode 4
ct2 w
apologies if I'm mumbling a bit it is
12:30 a.m. I spent four days at pack
South and a whole day at work before we
started
this boom boss you need to disable the
soviet's reinforcement system by putting
a hole in their Bas toas comms Network
okay am I going to be doing that the
whole time Communications post and
destroy it comm's equipment first use
the binoculars to locate the
communications equipment at the facility
okay
so I think what happened there is that
by picking that up I basically started
the
mission uh and
then I think it's still an open world
but it's just kind of keeps me enclosed
in these areas I think if I leave it
might stop it or something um so I need
to destroy the comm's
equipment is presumably in here the
target is there yep the map has been
updated what about here what the [__]
going on
here is that the place I went before I
think it is I think that's the it is
that's where Miller was so this is where
I started
so this is where I need to
go can I see anything else on the other
Maps
perhaps reset it that's
annoying who sorry if I'm going a little
fast
okay all right next mission what what
are
the identify com qu and Eastern Outpost
and then other one and it doesn't tell
me what the other ones are I wonder if
there's going to be some Rhyme or Reason
To those or if they're going to change
every single
time it's cool I think it's a good
balance between open
world sort of freedom and also oh [__]
that's exactly what they want to
[Music]
happen change weapon change weapon
change weapon change
weapon oh [__] did I get him
location is on your Android holy
crap not bad see
dude so I'm guessing I could probably F
in this truck if it wasn't for if I had
something bad good enough right subject
on board leave the rest to us but I can
I drive it oh [__] don't do
that vehicle controls here we go break
reverse accelerate binoculars move
vehicle hide you can hide like you can
hide
in the on the
horse and everything else seems normal
uh sub weapon main weapon and headlights
are the only thing I can see so that are
different so
headlights and then hide I can hit X and
hide but I can't hide while I'm
driving but that's
okay I wonder if they'll notice you
immediately thank you I was happy with
that shot 9:32 in the morning good
morning Spain it's at 12:00 a.m. in
tan hello to the other side of the
world I think you mean 10
p.m. if you're in the Teran I know
extraction arrived at all right let's
see if I'm able to so I can't shoot when
I'm in here I can use my
BX so just for shits and giggles let's
just drive through here and see what
happens I'm I'm still going
dude
or1 came up there I should have hit it
actually I didn't know what it was going
to
do can I just get
away uhoh spotted unidentified enemy
combat currently
engaging oh
[__] Titan Security on all
bases well this car is [__] resilient
uhoh
okay well In fairness it is actually a
bad
time I had a difficult mission to
do I'm just going to YOLO swagon the
whole way into this [__] base aren't
I got signs of an Intruders stay
alert I'm just going to try and knock
over as many of these guys as
possible in my
car
now this is some [__] Mad Max [__] oh
look coyotes come back here I want to
bring you to my mother
base this is a [__] stealth Action
right here hey what's up I don't want to
knock you down come
here good
boy come back to my base with
me good man oh hey it's your buddy
where'd you go come
here
don't you make me run after you arrived
at another
base come back
here I'll punch
you good
man oo it's halfast 12 in Seattle as
well how you doing you have arrived at
your hope you enjoyed packs hope you
went to packs
if you're in Seattle if you didn't maybe
check it out next year it's great show
it's my favorite video game show to go
to and I am fortunate enough to be able
to go to E3 and Gamescom and all that
good stuff and uh I [__] got this car
stuck though so I'm not getting back in
there
oh and yeah thanks everyone for watching
so far H we're about halfway through I'm
going to keep going till at least uh at
least 3: in the morning here so that's
only two and a half hours and if you're
watching on gaming.
youtube.com/ Gamespot hit that ad button
do a bunch of streams and videos over
here at gam spot first use the
binoculars to loc the communic W I
wonder where the
Russian
bases all right so they're on edge you
can see already
there scope in the place place
out yeah well it doesn't even let you
scan at that range you really have to
get in
there so the things I'm looking for are
this I'm
guessing no
really I'm looking for the comm's
equipment and the Eastern Communications
post I guess the two of
them identify and Destroy okay okay
okay there have some dudes hanging
out
um what's that that's an anti-air radar
got it it isn't one of the targets but
destroying it would
shutd that antenna is one of the targets
there should be more keep looking can I
just throw a grenade at it or do you
need me to see for it or oh [__]
[__] Somebody almost saw
me you still see me status of which
you're at least notable the enemy is
known as stealth mode to enter stealth
mode go prone stay still and hold the
action
button
gotcha who the [__] can see
me there a [__] seagull over me with
a GoPro on or
something also what the [__] is
that aha perfect Sandstorm time [__]
love you
Darude all right this could be very
dangerous but I'm going to [__] do
it
see if I can get down there a
bit come
on
specialist is posted
here okay good to
know then I guess I can just kill him or
knock him out
right so I'll knock him out and then Fon
his ass out of
here 30
% is it better now at the S Storm's past
yes it
[Music]
is oh [__] did he hear
the I think he might have seen the
Fon he's coming too Roger
that somebody got pulled away by a
balloon he
said
we [__] get him out of here as well
cuz they're coming
anyway this [__] music that's playing
in here you got to extract
him that radio is used to relay messages
between outposts take it out and the
mission's complete wait can I take take
that
poster I think I
can [__] they're
coming can I get this tape I want the
tapes yes I bet I could have got that
tape from that other one I have to go
back and get
it I can get that poster as well where
are the rest of the [__] dudes
though I think I can put oh
[__] oh this isn't going to go well at
all [__] I hit
him oh my God [__] no scoping these
guys is that just the two of
them
Jesus
[__] I don't know I mean I'm good at
video games I'm good at first person
shooters but even I'm thinking this game
might be a little bit forgiving on
the on the shooting
Jesus I don't really care about those
guys seeing me actually cuz it'll just
make them change the angle they were
coming from last time so I'm just going
to I'm just going to beine for this
Roger
that
[__] oh well that's [__] It Anyway
explosives should take care of them well
enough how you do it is up to
you all right we finally got ourselves a
[__] fight
here [__]
[__] all
right does that
work
nope but I killed some dudes in
there do I actually have any grenades
that's more like it that's the first one
destroy the remaining
antennas where the [__] are the
remaining
antennas Le I know what one looks like
now where the oh there's one is that
it yeah okay I can hit it from here an
is one of the targets there should be
more keep
looking [__] he can't throw them very
far can
he nice I have that poster as well that
wasn't the last of them though keep
going [__] is the last one
oh my suppressor is going be [__]
anyway I'm not really interested in
killing these guys it's amazing it's
like now that I know I can Fon everyone
it's like killing people is kind of
useless to me like
it's there's like no net use to
it
[__] he's also no point in not running
into cover
[Music]
either
[__] where's the other one is that it
there yep all
right I know where I'm here I know why
I'm
here
[__] hit the back of it
maybe an is one of the
TS mission
complete got it you've completed your OB
now get out of the Zone get the [__] out
of here now just pined myself into a
corner all right we'll get out of
here I mean I kind of want to kill some
of these [__] as well
now
any more
grenades got the carboard
box see what this look like oh my God
I'm spoiled I'm never going to
console head is okay tyr's coming over
he's been playing the game on PC for
like two hours now yeah you got to come
over and see how this looks on PS4 looks
okay it still looks really good here
still looks good yes but I'm been
playing it 4K at 30 locked amazing
what about 2k 60 I'm all about that 60
man you can do 2K 60 get that frame rate
is this it what is this right now this
is 60 man look how good this looks look
how good this looks this has to be 60
right yeah like if it's not it's it's
pretty
close this looks 60 to me yeah obviously
on the stream they're not going to get
that but no oh [__] grenade but it looks
really
good look this
[__]
you stay on the ground jerk
hole so we're uploading a clip right now
you're uploading a clip all right
gamespot.com is it YouTube only be on
YouTube is 4K only be on YouTube is 4K
oh yeah okay so it'll be on Gamespot if
you go to
youtube.com/ Gamespot you should be able
to or gaming. yoube oh [__] gaming.
youtube.com for/ gam spot you should be
able to get
it
uh a hot
4K 2K 60 situation of this game running
on PC sorry I probably shouldn't be
doing this while I'm trying to kill
these [__] how do I use my health
this is not the time to try and figure
that out all right [__] get out of
here no more
grenades really wish I had that car
now
damn yeah [__] total Rambo mode
man so I remember it was it was it was
pressed triangle
before wait who the [__] just saw
me oh
[__] yo [__] horse where you
at oh there you are I was
whoa whoa maybe
not anyone comes at me I'll shoot them
from my
horse
Jesus
Christ yeah that's what's
up let's get out of The Hot
Zone it's too hot too spicy we can't let
them follow you throw off the enemies on
your tail
first all right the ghost is clear
that's a lot of blood complete oh that
was not the best
uh extraction arrived at mother base not
the best grade I don't think I'm getting
for this one I got a great wolf though
the wolf baby was enough project has
been
added that made me feel
good mission complete all I got c c
b not too
bad look at all that [__] GMP
160k all that
heroism and then the credits roll
again thank you Soviet Armament regiment
H okay as requested I'm going to go back
and check out mother Bay see what's
going on there see how much I can uh add
to it how much you can change uh see if
there's any way of getting into a PVP
situation maybe there as well um but
we'll
see we shall
see what happens mother base
members base development unit has been
established interesting I wonder if
that's it is going like
crazy in fact it's getting downright
crowded around here to bring a greater
number of people on board we'll need to
expand our facilities to that end I've
created a base development unit it has
two roles material refinement and
platform construction ooh I'll start
with the material refinement part okay
the base development unit procures
material resources on a regular basis
according to its level the materials are
stored in containers and placed on the
deck of mother base once they're
finished being processed they can
finally be put to use by using these
materials to build new platforms we'll
be able to add a greater number I can
expand mother base I'm wondering if this
is we don't need any specific
instructions from you to refine the
material directly connected to the PVP
stuff to decide how we construct
platforms once we have sufficient GMP
and the required material resources you
can issue construction orders your
Android
okay oh hi death Rhino who a
surgeon I keep you Troublemaker violence
ooh he's a his skill is a troublemaker
that seems bit weird death a bloody
Mammoth hungry Ram cunning bat bitter
octopus and scowling
boa we don't even have any we don't any
A+ people is bad for the body and mind I
think it's time you took a break do it
for me dude I was already going to come
back ASAP I was already going to come
back but thank you for inviting me back
much
appreciated still a bit of hand holding
Happening
Here uh earlier in the game but uh that
is to be expected of a game of this
nature there's a lot of moving Parts
going
on resume
Game Dude clean your [__] face come
on
you got to you got to sort your [__] out
dude that's
not come
back a look at
it a that's what I I F in that
[__] here's the dog you brought back bit
of a
troublemaker not sure about the breed
though it'll get
bigger uh-huh like this
that is adorable you know I can look
after
him he's still a pug so he doesn't
listen a feeling someday he'll be
useful I suspect you discovered a real
diamond in the
r the little polish i' say we got a true
Diamond dog on our hands
yeah also he cleans the blood from my
face DD right
something wrong with his
ey
fine come on
didy I like
it DD you're all
[Applause]
right
just to remind you you can do it I
guess all right back a mother base we
received a back Channel request from
Langley we're to find a piece of new
American Military Hardware that's gone
missing in the mountains of
Afghanistan it's a difficult Mission but
I'd say you're back in top form by now
check your idroid for the details
[__] hyoid
man this [__] can do anything it can do
anything uh okay first of all I'm
actually going to take a little wander
around weather base cuz I've barely had
a look at it since we got
here presumably there's all gentlemen
that I have welcome home boss beaten to
death thank you
boss if the morale of mother base staff
increases this will raise staff
abilities above their inherent level
returning frequently to mother base is a
good way to raise staff morale that's
pretty cool what's over
here work in
progress safety comes from first thank
you for your
cooperation boss we're ready to develop
new equipment just give the order all
right I'll give the order in a bit let's
want have a little bit of a
look yeah I'm up early [__] keep
working what's up
here more things to expand upon there's
so much to
expand Let's uh let's get to it
development resources staff management
database it's all stuff for the
the Choppers and whatnot here we have
everything I need
for terms of all the stuff that I was
see I have no place weapons or Vehicles
cuz I can't pick them up yet boss do
need supplies we're here for you staff
management do I need to do anything with
these guys
unit uh Rd staff assigned select unit
have I not done this already are they
all on
assigned here we have waiting room R&D
base development
support so that's change assignments
that are already assigned so he's
assigns medical is that correct
unit select
unit oh yeah there it is so he's in
support the they all
support select unit okay select
unit and this is dead
ones interesting base facilities here we
go okay command platform
one I've got one of four I need I have
the GMP I need more minor medals I need
a thousand of that I need another 500
fuel resource to do that as well
uh Orange
platform base development platform and
support platform I don't even have any
any of the means to do
those uh but apparently our place is
getting a little bit too crowded so I
kind of need to sort this out pretty
soon
uh can I upgrade my current one is that
a thing construct and expand
bases increase maximum capacity so this
adds this extra deck to the command
platform uh these set up different
platforms I guess which then can be
upgraded as
well but obviously I am running into the
same problems by not having uh not
having enough stuff that'll put the or
staff up to 35 well all the staff limits
up to 35 but I need to pick up more to
do that um and that's number one so they
all go up to four levels I guess and
then within
those presumably I can do uh it'll just
give me more
resources so nice for him to ask me to
come back but actually I don't need to
come backass set tapes do I have any
sick
music only time will
tell
nice I want to go back to that other
base and get that other song I tried to
get it from the [__] cassette player
but it wouldn't let me what happened to
old mother base members oh Chico yeah
what the [__] happened there snake do
you remember Amanda yeah I do their
Revolution was a success Samoa resigned
and Nicaragua has a new government
Amanda is really working hard for her
country to be reborn good for them she
says she wishes Chico could be there
where is CH that Revolution was the
dream for Amanda for
Chico and their
father that Chopper was no place to die
I'd like to at least think history will
remember his part in the oh yeah God did
he that when you pick up a Gun there's
always a chance you'll die for nothing
he knew that as well as the rest now
that he's gone it's up to the rest of us
to decide what it was all worth if we
don't there's nothing to prove that
Chico ever lived at all where is Mark on
the
world uh okay told us that kind of want
to see is if the forward operating stuff
has at all kicked in uh let me just make
sure I'm actually
connected to their servers first of
all I really yeah you're right you know
what I [__]
serious can on you're totally right I
wish you would have a goddamn
shower it's filthy it's not becoming of
a
soldier um not sure what Konami servers
are doing at the moment we did log on at
the start of the stream but for some
reason it clicked off during the
prologue part um hopefully it'll just
connect up
here but I had too much of a fuss so for
those of you who don't know this is
obviously Metal Gear Solid 5 the phantom
P Metal Gear online will be coming later
this year which is
their like I guess whatever you want to
call it team multiplayer um
online uh component uh skirmishes and
and and and player versus player and
stuff uh or team versus Team rather uh
there is a PVP aspect to metal gear
solid five though called forward op
operating base fob which basically has
it so that you can log into other
people's um you can sort of invade their
mother bases uh and steal items from
them steal resources uh and then they
can do the same for you as
well which is a little bit
weird um this is hanging here as well
just so you know so hopefully it kicks
the [__] in apparently it's connected to
konami's uh servers so I don't know if
this if you've opt in some of that sort
of stuff if anyone can invade your base
if anyone steals my dog I'm going to
lose my [__] I'll tell you that right
now um apparently I
am connected Now power Nicaragua so I'm
not sure if that means I can do anything
else in the
missions supply drop mission list we
lost TCH with her till Amanda heard from
her out of the blue doesn't look like
it says I'm
connected this is all just normal F and
then in here
or something from the bottom of Lake
Nicaragua Amanda passed the request onto
her friend the new
Administration she's a national hero now
after all so strange love got a Soviet
military aircraft to transport something
to
somewhere the cargo wasn't big enough to
have been Peace Walker itself so what
was it who knows we recovered peace
Walker's nuclear warhead ourselves 9
years ago what could Strange Love have
been after Amanda said she didn't
mention I'm going to shut this tape off
[__] annoying me Nicaragua is a
socialist State now with Amanda vouching
for her the government find it before it
ends with the details C Strange Love
told Amanda was that she was going to
continue her
research shut up all right sorry about
that folks H okay I can't see it
here doesn't seem to be it there is a
very good chance that this does not
unlock yet a mission as is the way of
the rest of this game that we are
getting uh drip fed this stuff piece by
piece so uh it doesn't look like it uh
this is being played on PlayStation
4 and we're uh we're uploading some sort
of footage I'm going to check the
YouTube gam spot I can't in a second
we're uploading some 4K 2K 60 stuff to
uh to the YouTube slot right now but uh
I'm going to keep playing here we're
about uh 3 hours 4 hours actually into
our play uh into our live stream here uh
let's check out the next mission over
the fence extract the engineer who tried
to defect the Soviet base G but is now
being held at waxin Barracks or recover
the US military's new weapon code named
honeybee hidden that SMY Fort the
Soviets are also after
it this one ss fun SS difficult
too let's do this one [__] it area of
operations is different except Mission
with the aial command center
what
ooh I not let do that
yet Mission types missions available all
missions every different except
Mission
interesting I guess I just have to call
oh really you just that's a bit obtuse
of you did I just have to call the
chopper in just to
start all
right pick me up please S Landing
Zone unless I can get in here and maybe
then suddenly let me this
isly at L maybe that'll let me do the
forward operation base stuff I don't
know
interesting H the footage is not up on
YouTube
yet LC I'll uh let you guys know when it
hits it oh the dust in my face it's
getting all my blood
Dusty and we go
uh this event started 4 hours ago at 900
p.m. Pacific here in San Francisco
California we're currently 1 a.m. in the
morning it's been a rough
ride but don't worry I got all the die
Cokes and red bulls
and Chinese food to keep me keep me
good that's what happened folks when a
great game comes out when the game gets
10 out of 10 on Game
Spot and you have it early you play it
as early as you can can and this was the
earliest we could stream it for you
folks so we got up and did
it and now I got to charge my dual
shock let's plug this guy
in yeah so thanks uh to everyone for for
hanging in really appreciate here on
games gamespot.com or if you're watching
on gaming.
youtube.com Gamespot or you're watching
on twitch.tv/
Gamespot my goodness
uh yeah hopefully snake has decided to
wash off some of the blood on his face
in between now the SE shells
and
Afghanistan how far are the [__] SE
shells from
Afghanistan it's got to be pretty far
right I'm going to look it up I'm going
to look it
up on Google
Maps SE shells directions to
Afghanistan this is probably
a probably a search term not often used
on Google Maps but I imagine right now
it'll probably be used a lot wow the SE
shells I did not realize they were that
close of madag gas card that's pretty
[__]
far that's a long
track side Ops list upd by connec yourid
to the computer you turn the chopper
into your own aerial Command Center or
ACC need a 16 hour
flight and it only pered from there as
as you to consider all your options
gotcha okie dokie I'm not going to
listen to all this [__] now but thank
you for the
offer uh okay
Miss okay doesn't seem to want to swap
for some
reason
actually stuck on this menu for some
reason it apparently is
loading
so I don't know where was the chopper
before this another Landing Pad that's a
very good [__] question my friend
Patrick
Jones good question it was just hanging
out okay so that's it was hanging there
for some reason because the internet
connection was lost so I'm guessing
konami's servers are getting a shocking
at the moment
accept this
Mission danger low Afghanistan let's get
there need to take a shower at your base
of operations you think you think
Serius I like my look like this floating
helicopter select
equipment I don't have a different type
do I really not need to get some more I
wonder if I can pick them up while I'll
do it your weapons bionic
arm how do you need to use that more
support
weapons we got everything we
need I think we're
good uh still can only pick snake really
interested to see where that looks
please yes I cleaned him thank [__] for
that yeah that's more like it you filthy
son of a [__] let's get in there kill
some [__] 6 in the morning I'm
morning type of person let's do
it uh William snap why does the pilot
have the same voice actor as the one
from Grand zeros H that is not the pilot
that is uh that is oelas talking to me
from inside of my mind or inside of my
iPad that stuck in my brain or whatever
the [__] reason this game was
working oh my
goodness yes Mad Max did not get the
best uh view from gamespot.com got six
out of 10 which is a little bit of a
shame I played that at
uh Gamescom a couple of weeks ago and it
seemed okay for the first whatever 20 30
minutes I played but obviously in
Long
Long large amounts it's not as fun Mo
gaming asked Danny the final boss
spoiler Mad Max review is that
intentional I actually haven't read that
yet so I can't say I'll have to ask
Peter if that is the case
I'll have to ask him see what
about ratings are for knowing if you
should buy it or not ratings are for
knowing if what other people think about
the game make your own decision about
whether do you want to buy something or
not the honey must be hidden at theire
try to stealth this Mission I
will did anyone a Game Spot play the
PlayStation 3 version you have to get to
it before they do bring it back here let
me check there's aoto of
theid still is one Apparently one of the
fighters
I forgot this game was coming out on 360
and PS3 and no no one has yet good
luck I don't think we have codes for PS3
or Xbox 360
yet recover the honeybee weapon system I
will once I shoot
everyone careful down
there don't worry I got my trusty
Steed okay let's do this one
as stealthily as possible this is quite
the the distance the Afghan um roads
aren't exactly the most uh easily
navigable I've ever
seen this is where we're going honey has
got to be somewhere in that Fort but the
search area is too wide we need
something to point us in the right
direction okay so there's a gunship as
well going around which is going to be
interesting okay I'm going to have to
get my ass the whole
way down past this
Outpost R this relay
station and this other post and then in
there this is going to be a bit of a
mission
folks looking forward to
it off we go deag dog or whatever your
[__] name is I'm face away yeah I am
I'm yeah if you screw up enough times
they put you in a chicken hat it's
pretty
funny I still haven't figured out how I
uh how I heal myself though I should
probably get on
that scanny scanny
scanny there's a
dude there's another dude
a Soviet Soldier a lot of them came from
Central Asia before but lately they've
been using more and more Russians simple
really there's less hesitation to pull
the trigger if they're not fighting
their own race moreid cynicism but it
gets
results that's Humanity for you War as
hell yeah this guy he's going to be dead
in a second or maybe he'll be Fon to my
base I haven't decided
yet one of those two
though I wish I had a snip
sniper these guys are not protecting the
other side of that base very well
they're pretty forgiving on the horse
stuff as
well how are you doing Eric
Tay fine you sleepy little bit sleepy
let's approaching 2: a.m. where we are
here last night s the two last night
were you playing Destiny
light playing
Diablo you are Diablo
yourself nope all right that's what the
kids call it
what you think I should do
here I mean I'll be honest I really like
just throwing grenades at people
but I should be fing then like if you
got someone good they start helping you
upgrade your mother base I like
upgrading my base but I also like
straight up ganking
fools they're pretty for I feel like
they're pretty forgiving on the on these
I'm not going to go for that one that's
a bit too much but I feel like the
accuracy is a little bit forgiving which
is fine I'm just used to melar solid too
where it's like missing you see some
missing no man I've been [__] killing
people I did you see that shot of the
guy that was in the GU was in the car oh
whoops look at this I'm in stealth mode
you got to put your head
down that's key for subtle and
breathing I need to get the [__] away
from here
how long till you think you get that
nice cardboard box the with the lady on
it I should probably be able to I I got
so many posters I thought they were
going to let me use the posters as the
ladies on the carboard boxes cuz I
picked one up I especially got this
really pretty lady poster but the game
is having none of it where's this guy
let's see if he comes down to the
box I can whistle sometimes but it won't
let me it only let me call dehorse I
really want to do right now come on come
over
here see if he notices me turn
around turn
around come on notice
me
really
Esports
baby Esports would have been you doing
it right when you popped out yeah that's
true I took my sweet
time watch this [__] this is
Esports boom eat it guard
postured that was all right was it
okay I can't uh I can't F in him from
here because that wouldn't be realistic
cuz he'd hit
that but now I
can even though I can fult in things
that are inside of
buildings this game is so dumb uh what
about you can I F FL in you you on the
wrong side of this
fence how about now 100% extract him I'm
going to extract
everybody
look at this toilet
situation portable toilet you're going
to hide inside watch the enemy doesn't
decide to use it yeah I hope they don't
same goes for hiding down enemies in
it like dumpsters you can Contin Fallen
enemies inside toilets or hide inside
and wait for enemies to pass no point
intended unlike dumpsters you cannot
drag an enemy in while hiding
inside but if you open the door at the
right moment you can send an enemy
flying and neutralize them oh that's
pretty cool can I duck down
good
night can I choke the chicken
no get all this sweet
swag is that a diamond [__] yeah it's a
diamond ra diamonds collecting them as
assets will raise our GMP of course it
will sell on the black
market actually I assume we're selling
all of this on the black
market ooh I can Shine the Light of
people not much use right now but
whatever good to know blind
people still I can't pick these up
because they're too heavy that's okay
all right I got to I'm going to pick up
this gun as well cuz I haven't been
picking up enough of those although was
I going to drop my own one uh don't want
to do that it's got a suppressor on
it better fult in this ass hat while I'm
here always nice to be able to hide in
toilet I can't fult in him from here
this is going to be a problem because I
also don't think I can climb down with
him so I'm just G have to throw him
hopefully he survives the fall and then
I can fault in
him but I think he might be dead he's
dead
okay what a shame I would have got 19
rounds left on that
uh uh on that suppressed pistol or or
rather dart gun so I better be a little
bit careful with it where's deor gone oh
there you are hi dehorse old buddy o pal
let's continue our murderous Rampage of
Afghanistan uh that's the first one
hopefully there's not any more left
we'll hit this relay
base this is our our our destination
there's also a gunship floating around
this whole area so we got to be a little
bit careful of that hopefully on the way
we'll run into some
uh some friendly uh fora and
Flora so we can collect some plant life
and uh
and aminals for our for our mother
base I'm not going to take the road I'm
going to Robert Frost this [__] and uh
take the road not taken see if we can
get a high vantage
point this a poetry reference there for
all you
kids bam bam bam bam
bam I guess it didn't matter I'm loving
the lighting it's really
impressive T about
oh yeah yeah tyr says we got 4K going at
about 50 55
FPS that's with 3 980s right dang looks
any any hot gameplay hitting the site
yeah we're right now
awesome oh really
nightmare think there's something in
there that look at
this this looks real
pretty so relay base so I can probably
get something in
here God look at that those mountains
are so
cool Sky boxes look at that heat look at
that heat happen in
there it's like [__] fall out here
with all
these bit of wind a lot of
desert I mean I'm playing a lot of
Fallout at the
moment on my own channel I'm playing
Fallout and naked and gunless at the
moment which is proving
difficult that's on a dard dwire if you
want to add on that
one but for here oh what's going on here
is that prisoner the H Survivor if he is
he has to know something about the
honeybee sounds
good
any more
dudes God the size of these bases is
really
cool what else we
got
I'm Mor them down
here and no this is not Solid Snake
Solid Snake is
uh likely not
even actually 21 years
before M Gear Solid
I don't know he probably is right this
is
84 like saw 2005 he wasn't [__] 21 in
that
game he was pretty old already so I
don't
know so here's the thing I don't need to
spend all my time going down that road
and killing every single person here if
I want to stealth my ass in here it's
probably a clever way of doing it
h of course clever and safe are not
always the same
thing the wormwood also known as
absentium used to make your Phantom
cigars very cool give me this
guy getting all them plants oh
[__] that was a little bit scary all
right I'm going to slide my ass down
here that was very Geral of Rivia of
him
here we
go big boss is the original snake that
is
correct boss get down the enemy sniper
stay low and crawl along the ground that
should enable you to sneak past enemies
[__] oh thank you
Sandstorm you little beauty oh [__]
really is he still able to see
me the
man he's just a gift that keeps on
giving I don't know how long these
things last
though
so I don't care if he doesn't actually
get up there I just want to get rid of
his body so I'm going to use the Fulton
anyway I mean there's a 30% chance of it
working but if he dies on the way that's
fine by me I just don't have enough time
to hide his body failed yeah all right
guess he's dead whatever still got rid
of his body'll do for
me
okay
I guess I want to get up here but I'm
not sure if I want to get the whole way
up on this
side
hanging let me
check yeah I guess I can I just want to
see if it's connected on the other
side L off onter happened a few years
before this okay
yeah I would have thought so I didn't
didn't think he was that he wasn't 21
anyway okay I'm going to go up here I
don't want
to risk seeing is getting
involved with all those guys on the way
up so I'm going
to do some of it here there's going to
be one or two people on the way up here
but I think I've
cleared that one
guy and hopefully I'll get the jump on
them
I like how the binoculars isn't as
forgiving as something like fary 3 or 4
where sorry excuse me where you're um oh
[__] hands up
[__] okay give me
information
talk your friend the map has being
updated [__] it I'll kill
him I do
it he gave up information I don't want
that in a
soldier
he didn't tell me the location of some
uh some stuff though where's
that down there H too late for that
now maybe on the way back we'll
see okay anyone else up
here I don't think I want to go up one
more I think I want to stay down to this
lower
area and go across the
bottom
getting some advice from people have
already played this far nice
work my man ahed when you got the other
side of the bridge go in the two little
hits Huts there's a lot of raw materials
in there I'll do my best thank
you what would I tell his family oh
[__] ay maybe I'm a little bit too much
exposed on this
side see it is a problem I'm going to
keep having because I'm
not I'm not equipped with anything with
any long
distance oh that guy's coming over
[__] [__] [__] [__] [__]
[__] [__]
off is that a helicopter do I hear a
[__]
helicopter I knocked that guy out did he
do it on did he get up
there did they kill that [__]
dude
[__] Le I'm on the right side of the uh
barade
dock
oh do your best [__]
yeah [__] all
right [__] [__] sniper hit
me oh great they're sending back up as
well
so much for
stealthy I was that sniper I'd be
hitting that red Barrel but he obviously
didn't can I get what was in this
radio
[__] I can't get that sniper I'm never
never going to be able to get
there he leaving there for his buddy to
get
him that death to field is really nice
can I destroy that while to do
anything yeah sure
dead
that so
cool
[__] God damn it I'm covered in blood
again oh this is [__] cool I love
this Jesus [__] reload already
[__] grenade go go go go
go all right I'm too close for
comfort oh God damn it all right it'll
be interesting to see where it puts me
back that was fun around snake snake
snake no gunshot when I got
killed oh yes in the midst of a battle
he will only use a tranquilizer that is
the way I work I'm like [__] Batman
out
here man oh back here really new usary
weapon known as the honey it should be
I'm going to go for a second there's
aoto of IDE on this
one I'm glad I did this actually this is
a super fun way of playing this this
reminds me of old days playing games
like half lifee 2 this time around I'm
gonna go
get this
[__] get the
sniper a Soviet relay base I think
there's also one of these guys up for me
to
attack that's Communications equipment
used by The Outpost CP it must be how
they keep in touch with headquarters if
you
to cut off the CP
from I don't have any C4 ending though
that's the problem so we'll see what
happens
aay if you're just joining us welcome
I'm currently doing
Mission let say six I think it's six of
me your solid
five the phantom
pain I think I'm on the right side of
that Sniper Tower yep he's facing the
other
way I don't have much in the way of
equipment which is kind of causing me a
little bit of hassle
but that guy just turned around so I
should be okay
oh they both
turned all right used a bit more than
I'd like to
but got the job
done let's fting these guys out of
here
all right number
two subject on board lead the rest to
us now is there a way of sabotaging
this equipment up here without having to
blow it up he's coming too Roger that or
I wonder if I do blow it up with a
grenade again if I'm able
to I wonder if I'm able to [__] punch
it to death
actually now at the snow storms then I
can probably or the sandstorms then I
can
probably just grenade the [__] thank
you
Darude got it
good
nope that's not what I wanted to
hear that's literally the opposite of
what I wanted to
hear what I wanted to hear was oh no
we've lost Communications with
HQ uhoh I guess we'll have to fix that
thing the sniper actually come down off
his post so I wonder if he's the close
oh here we
go so what I kind of want to do is get
that
sniper so then I can get his gun and
start to finish some of these [__]
off cuz they're kind of out in the open
like I was totally out in the open when
I when I got stuck
so
one
down I hear screaming which isn't a
good good
sign yep I love
that I guess the way to do this is get
in the sniper perch
but oh [__] he's only got Six
Bullets switch
comma let's get up there and get some
more
shots
[__]
niely done I like that
little little flasho
kill does it go through that do you
think
nope three shots
left they from the babies downstairs
they might
be all
right fting your ass out of here
[__]
this guy's doing a really terrible job
of keeping
cover heroism minus 10 is that what that
said oh my God oh my God that's terrible
I shot that guy and he's on the ground
I'm not their hero
anymore yeah Rebel Yell 199 9 remaster
how the [__] does that make any sense
this is like
1975 oops can I Fon you guys you guys
want to get
[Music]
Fon all right let's get some [__]
music in
here
this is so [__]
dumb don't worry about me dudes just
hanging out on your
bridge wasn't a kill shot
[__] that was the one I needed to be a
killer
shot
[__] on just get these two guys
and not can to make a run for it ah
there's a
third
yeah head
shot look at all you guys line them
up this [__] accuracy on this gun is
really
impressive no more heroism for
me is he dead stay down stay
down holy [__]
okay go go go go
go don't send back up I [__]
destroyed your connection to the CP so
don't even
try circle strafe circle strafe circle
[Music]
[Laughter]
strafe who's
alive
all
right it's a little bit weird having the
1999 remix of this song but
whatever let's give me all that [__]
give me all that
metal can f in these bodies
right there's some
more good to know they don't get
destroyed
look at this
[Music]
guy anything in here work
keeping [__] yeah there is so all this
stuff is what's going to do uh going to
upgrade my base upgrade mother base oh
these L other pictures of doggies and
things how
lovely
helicopters sweet
posters that transition internet of
builing is really weird watch
[Music]
this singes the
eyes all
right keep
going hey yeah the music is in game
Sorry For Those you watching the stream
who were wondering
why if Rebel Yell is playing on some
sort of commercial or something it's
actually it's actually in there use
Phantom cigar uh
okay there you go I love the
cigar there might be Clues to the
target's location at that Outpost take a
look around doesn't want to work right
now
really
yeah there you go so the cigar at fast
forwards
time there we are six 6 in the evening
so now it's getting
uh getting nice and Light the song for
some reasonbly was still
playing but this still mean obviously
that it's uh little less visibility
which will work in my favor and against
my
favor uh probably an equal an equal
measure
that guy's looking for me
already I don't think this is the final
base this is just another shitty little
base just got to close the distance man
I got to Usain VT this [__] hopefully
nobody hits me with a
segue okay you know what I'm turning off
this [__] music
[Music]
you more like
it now back
to back to the good
[__]
they're all patrolling around the back
here so I guess I could
just don't turn don't look don't look
don't look all right I guess I could
just go back here and wait for them to
isolate themselves on the
patrol
forgot that thing didn't have a
silencer this one so does
though
is he the only one here so it's like the
smallest
base I think it is yeah I like that I
like the fact that the silencers run out
so it's not like you've got a silenced
weapon that is
uh that you're slowly losing ammo for
it's just
that you kind of can't afford to I guess
it's like hey you know what if you're
going to go in all guns blazing then I
guess you're not going to neede this
silencer anymore
right I really don't want to have to
make any more noise
man perfect timing nice work you got to
F in your ass out of
here my
God all right let's pick up some of
these beautiful common Metals I've
actually picked up a lot in this base so
I wonder if it's
a going to make a
difference don't worry about it bro
don't worry about it I got you I got
youed because he's underneath this
awning I have to move
him for I thought I send his ass out of
here
okay some more ammo for that sniper
rifle would be good I wonder if I'm now
that I've uh unlocked it I wonder if
it's easier for me to get ammunition for
it that's used to make your Phantom
cigars if you have any questions at all
you've just joined in I've been playing
the game for five hours uh Daniel dwire
from Gamespot here if you've got any
questions by all means put them in the
chat on Gamespot on Twitch on YouTube
whatever you want I'll keep an eye at do
my best project has been added ooh hand
grenade that's good actually you know
what I'm going to do which I haven't
done in a little while is get a supply
drop I think I can do from here as well
I don't think they're going to
be please select a drop point without
particular Let's uh let's just do it
there and see what
happens item surpresses
use sure supplies requested oh I wonder
if that means I'm not not going to get
sniper ammo then because I didn't uh cuz
I haven't researched it yet I guess
we'll find out in just a little
bit yeah keeping an eye out for
questions there
folks supply drop
complete and your quest as well uh
please let me
know and here comes the Box
all right next time I do that I have to
remember to knock somebody out with
it pick them all up um yeah nothing for
the sniper rifle what are you going to
do got a fresh suppressor on the on that
guy though so that's not too bad I'd
like to know if you can charge people on
the horse to knock them over if you
could demonstrate perhaps yes you
definitely can I did it before and I
might demonstrate if I'm stuck in a
situation
where uh the base has been alarmed but
I'm not going to right here if I can
help my ass because we're about to get
into this situation where there's a
[__] gunship and there's a massive
base but uh yes you can definitely knock
people over and and it
works and sorry keep an eye on questions
here as
well looks like you'll be going to
mother base to start some research
projects yes right after this one H
would the supply drops get you noticed
by the bad guys I imagine so because the
fullon recovery system does so even when
I tried
to uh balloon some people out of here it
still it still did it uh what is your
score out of 10 so far personally ah
it's hard to do that without having a
sort of a holistic idea about the game
I'm definitely enjoying it it it it
feels almost nothing like a a numbered
Metal Gear Solid game it feels a lot
more like a bigger version of um of
ground zeros which I really liked but it
was kind of limited um the one thing I'm
actually finding is that oh [__] look at
these guys and the one thing I'm finding
is it's actually a little bit easy so I
think I might turn up
the uh the difficulty a little bit
because I wonder if I can I wonder if
that's even possible let's
[Music]
check chicken hat off sorry we should
probably turn that on
[Music]
right oh they haven't done the chicken
hat so the chicken hat is um
if you if you get killed a bunch of
times the chicken hat is
basically a sort of
a all right let's make sure they're gone
the chicken hat essentially if you it
pops on your head if you've died a bunch
of times to like humiliate you for for
being uh shitty and it also demonstrates
that the game has been set to an easier
mode so I guess I've just enabled that
um I couldn't see anything else in terms
of uh display game yeah I guess it's
just locked on in
there uh yeah but it's uh yeah I'm
finding a little bit too easy a little
bit uh supply drop shouldn't be noticed
but you need to be aware of where you
Dro them so you can acquire Amo being
seen yeah I actually do think they might
be noticed just because of had of full
work I know you can knock people out
with them so if you land your supply
drop on top of somebody will actually
knock them out so that's also the fact
yeah do the balloons ruin the stealth
they kind of make the carrying bodies
useless yeah so like I was able to like
get rid of something with a Fulton even
though I knew it probably wasn't going
to make it back because the Fultons are
you know based on weather and whatnot uh
but the the Fons do
also
uh uh will allow you to be seen if
you're if you're doing it in a populated
area H and I guess they do kind of in a
way like something of an Ancor to the
domestic so far like I what I'll say is
that the types of B that I've been
approaching haven't been very difficult
so I've never I haven't had that much
emphasis on really trying
to have a hard time stealthing because
you always got you always got to jump on
people as well so it kind of it hasn't
hasn't been a problem as of yet but yes
I can I it definitely feels like the uh
disposing of bodies or the hiding of
bodies has much less of a priority than
I did in something like metal gear three
or two when the areas were a lot tighter
and there was a lot more um footfall
shall we say between each uh between
each
objective H what are your thoughts on
the story uh taking a backseat to the
gameplay for the first time like the
first two hours are pretty story heavy H
pretty crazy the opening prologue is
[__] insane that's an enemy gunship
single burst from his machine gun can
cut a man in half where's the gunship
carefully boss oh it's right ahead of
us I'm going to stealth
myself H but I I like it so far like in
a weird way this doesn't really feel
like a melar solid
game it feels much more like a sequel to
ground zeros than it does anything like
M your Solid
4 so uh yeah I don't know so far I'm
liking it but then I'm not somebody who
would really go crazy for the story like
I I've always enjoyed it sort of
ridiculousness but I'm not one to
uh to go crazy about it why not
cardboard box stealth tactics yet uh
dude you have not been watching the
stream very long I've been carboard
boxing the [__] out of this all I bet
that cardboard box bam
that little dust spark when you do that
is the best part of this game just going
to say I'm scared about a sniper here
but I don't see any so I'm going to go
because the [__] Chopper is gone
atase let's get our ass in there and
what console is this on I'm playing on
PlayStation 4 currently uh there's some
30 frames a second 4K footage going up
on uh YouTube on the Gamespot Channel
ASAP but uh uh we're also going to get
some 60 frames per second stuff up there
or like 50 55 but the problem is the
YouTube stuff isn't particularly great
at doing that H keep an eye on the
Gamespot chat there as well if you guys
are you guys are chin wagging in
there and of course twitch I'll keep an
eye on you as well from time to time uh
Danny's the guy who does the point on
YouTube that's correct the Irish accent
is a
giveaway yeah oh [__] [__]
duck I do a bunch of stuff on Gamespot I
do a bunch of live streams as well on
Gamespot we have a live show
every Tuesday at 2 p p.m
Pacific uh also do more sort of long
form gameplay stuff on my own YouTube
channel dwire but we're going to do a
lot more on Gamespot over the coming
weeks and months actually so make sure
you hit that add button
here is the PS4 running 6 60 frames per
second so it is that's
great uh and it's G to kill me going
back to play The Witcher on this thing
well I actually play on PC and Xbox One
But same difference on the Xbox
one so if I can help but I want to get
through here without attacking these
dudes I'm also a little bit worried
about the yeah these guys are on the way
back aren't
they no they're just staying there okay
one of them is on the way
back [__] and so is this uh
gunship ooh look at that guy all the way
over there what's he
doing I'm glad it's night time how much
night time's left so 10 10 in the game
[__] did it see me if I hit triangle it
basically puts me in like deeper stealth
mode
there hell yeah alt F1
represent and yes I am the one who
interviewed Daniel Bryan sorry about
that oh
where's that guy down there I want to
kill him but not if the other guy we'll
see all right I'm going to show you the
Fon right
now nope I'm
not I take it
back I instead I'm going to hide this
body and flank the base you think I can
get around that way Mar removed oh yeah
I totally
can all right so in that situation I
could have Fen the body but the guy
would have seen it actually she thought
I was going to get away with it but I
didn't I picking him up so maybe just
fing would have done the job anyway cuz
they kind of just notice it and walk
over um but for now I'm just going to
keep my keep my ass down this
road I need to get in here as quickly as
possible let's through this past
so could have call for my horse but I'm
just going to just going to gun
it get a bit of
exercise
I don't think they're going to find that
guy so I should be
okay extraction arrived at another
Bas Sal s and his brother are 12 years
old in 1984 according to the chat
according to di
J something tells me they will come up
at some stage in this game
[__]
okay they're making the way up there so
that's kind of the area I'm trying to
get to Sandstorm Darude
Darude [__]
yes down you go
babies so this is a situation in which I
could just fol in their asses and the
chances are they wouldn't make it back
but their bodies would at least
disappear uh I can also use my life
Visions to get a better read
of if there's any bodies in the
immediates but there's
not so what I'll do is I'll get up
here and keep an eye down there and see
if I
can get a shot away at whoever's down
there actually you know what there's a
better spot down there [__]
helicopter where is it it's going down
that way I D the helicopter can see dead
bodies
right that'll just be a little bit too
much
a hind
D nice blue plant stand
there oh there's a nice plant there
black carrot
delicious these shiny plants got to get
them
all
all right let's get our eyeses in
there you you know what they really
showed up some guards here like that's
that's a
no-brainer development project has been
added ooh development project has been
added let's check it
out you just do all that [__] from here
as well buddy equipment please specify a
project ooh battle dress for deor that's
pretty
cool base facilities can I make
something else while I'm
here nope still don't have enough of
that
[__] can I make an R&D
platform I can can I unable to
construct I need more
fuel they're standing down
great all right I'm going to start at
mot base later on once I've uh once I've
done more of this
actual important
work you need to retrieve the new US
military weapon known as the honeybee it
should be hidden somewhere in SMI Fort
there's a photo of the honeyb on yourid
give me the
photo all right looks like a [__]
weapons crate great it's going to be
helpful all right it's in here somewhere
don't know exactly
where
what's
that
okay and I don't think the chopper comes
in here does
it I can hear it outside but yeah I
don't think it's getting its ass in here
so I should be okay you have arrived at
your
destination okay
okay nobody in
there
maybe there's some swag up here
perhaps Phantom Pain
yeah
[__] [__] I N is body
so well this isn't a [__] good
start
[__] shut up
demet well that's not a good [__]
start is
it that's for
Le now to find the
honey is that it right
there no that's a car we may need to use
that if this gets a bit
uh gets a bit shooty which it probably
will because I'm an idiot and walked out
directly to the first [__] soldier
that saw
me oh my goodness get the [__] down
kid
suppressor on this thing is not going to
last too much
longer
keep them coming keep them
coming the enemy's given up their search
for you good but they're not giving the
all clear just yet [__] stay
alert this [__] gun is accurate I'll
say that
much right another tape over there oh
[__]
your suppressor is worn out that gun
will be as loud as
any guess that's
that you're getting out of here buddy
sorry [__]
okay [__] at the
fan I need to get the cover go go go go
go go go extract him
keep going keep going keep going keep
going all right scan the rest of them
before they wake
up all right you guys in the chat think
I'm dead you think I'm
dead what the [__] was that that a
flare they just launch a flare so they
could see me
man I wish I had my magic cigar right
now that another FLIR or is that a
grenade what the
okay maybe I am
dead yaa okay I like it definitely gets
more difficult one you've been
seeing don't land here oh
great guess the first was a warning
shot holy
[Laughter]
[__] oh I ate it ate it boss com in Boss
how about that mortar fire that was a
Game Changer boss doesn't quite have the
same ring as snake but
whatever box probably would have saved
me it's a good [__] activating Ste
assist a chicken know as the honey
[__] somewhere in stupid chicken
head honey on yourid a it's all floppy
and
stuff
a
God damn
it well this is humiliating
for I was about to say snake but for me
really oh [__] almost did the same thing
again they'll never see me with my
chicken
hat come here you
[__] you have arrived at your
destination he's arrived at his
destination [__]
death ha killed by a
chicken I wish you came this early last
time cuz it would have definitely solved
a lot of my
[Music]
problems the chicken hat is real
I mean I'm sure I could shoot these out
right
yeah it's good thing my chicken head is
so
luminous so beautiful and
illuminous
good Night
Irene [__] Irene's Brothers right
there hold your
breath
nope that's like it that's more like
it let's got a
fon let see if the Fon attracts them
this close oh [__]
does like [__] what was that
ballooner for Le now to find the
honey
all
right well I guess they're all pissed
off
again but this time I have the chicken
hat
all right should I go after him I feel
like I don't want him seeing
his did you hear that chicken
noise what the [__] was
that he just gave me a little chicken
noise like it was giving me a little bit
of a hand when I killed that guy that's
some
[__]
ah hey you know what if I'm going to get
[__] done for this I might as well
buol in as many of these jerk offs as I
can there's a lot of [__] bodies over
here and I can't let any of you Joker
see them
so could you please
stop you please stop coming over here
trying to get the bodies that'd be
great
boom
[__] hear that chicken sand again out
that gun will be as loud as any other
now I don't care I'm going to fult on
all these guys and you can't do anything
about
it that guy's reaction's amazing
like what the [__] was
that all
right you're still working my chicken
gun
friend good Night
Irene [__] here's another
one they're everywhere like a swarm of
chickens oh that won't [__]
do oh I have to reload fine
fantastic oh
look what's he
doing what is he doing is he like
ignoring me cuz I'm a
chicken what do you [__]
you is this like baby mode because I got
the chicken hat on God damn it I can't
complete this Mission like this that's
[__]
I don't even want to F in this guy I got
to shoot him in the [__] face
now what's
that o another sexy
poster all right maybe I get the sexy
poster maybe
I'll that wasn't a sexy poster that was
a regular poster
maybe maybe I'll just complete this
Mission then one come come back always
come
back do all the extra objectives and do
it properly without the stupid
humiliating chicken face situation going
on get all these things so I can upgrade
mother
base and I can get better equipment so I
don't have to be stupid humiliated
Chicken Boy
anymore on a live stream from of all
these people there's a diamond over
there I see
it I saw it I saw a shiny
thing
and apparently the weapon is inside that
building I kind of like the the fact
that the suppressors are gone again so
now I it's not like I can even it's got
to be really hard to like stealth my way
in from
here come here
[__] tell me your secrets or
I'll feed you to my chickens
[Music]
talk where are your friends the map has
been
updated I chy to
death your news I'm not killing you so I
can't use any more heroism because
honestly I think the chicken's probably
taken most of
it give me more of
this that material it could be just what
we need to develop new weapons and
equipment great that's what I want to
hear that is what I want to
hear uh where are the blueprints
at takes a long while to open those
things I guess they you got to make sure
there's no one around uh where the
blueprints
at on the weapons there
there that's where the mortar
is materials
are all right I'm just going to get in
there what's
that who
knows sexy
poster and these guys are inside the
building
and I don't think there's any snipers so
I should be
okay but there's also a good chance that
I'm an idiot and I'm going to have to
fight my way out of here so my problem
is I I don't I don't have the
opportunity to like close the distance
anymore if somebody spots me then I'm
going to have to discharge my weapon
which means I'm going to have
to make a lot of noise another base I
think this is a new checkpoint
though
is the weapon back
there or have I just Mar made my own
marker no I actually have I've wandered
in too far God damn it God damn it Ty
I'm wearing a chicken hat is that cuz
you suck it's cuz I suck
apparently I suck and it's cuz it's 2:
a.m. and I've been up for 24 hours
almost you want to hear who really sucks
who really sucks why do you really suck
D because I wasn't running in Tri oh you
weren't I was [__] wondering why it
wasn't a 1080 60 it's a 4K 60 it's 4K 60
great we've got running a 4K 60 on PC
fantastic close to 60 look all this [__]
I got look at this give me that
tape I'll be having
that my
goodness there's the mortar Target no it
definitely isn't there definitely isn't
there all right I'm happy I got the
tape now I got to stop nobbing that and
get back in there it's been a long day
time it's been a long week of packs been
a long full day of work and then we
started doing this at 900 p.m. it's
coming up with 216
a.m. I'm wearing a chicken hat how do
you get that thing off you get that off
by not being a noob okay got it h the
chicken hat thing is basically if you
die they make you wear a chicken hat and
then
you see that it's like that [__] does
it
again look at this guy this [__] is
going to come in and kill me cuz he's
sprinting in here for some [__]
unknown reason why you sprinting in here
what's going on what the [__] he saw a
chicken did he he saw a chicken he's
hungry right he he going to have a he's
he's telling his boys to come now I'm
going to tell him to
[__] he Dash dirty prick uh all
right I'm going to keep going through
here I don't trust they're checkpointing
it might be upstairs or some
[__] I'm looking for the honeybee
Ty I'm looking for the weapon of mass
destruction I mean you guys looked for
the weapon of mass destruction for
months and didn't find it so I think I
should probably be allowed a certain is
that a [__] is that a butterfly I
thought I saw a pretty butterfly I was
about to look at it and think about the
dichotomy of war and
life the
[__] Jesus
Christ if you die get the chicken hat
yeah if you've got chicken hat turned on
and you
die then they stick this on you and also
people people react to you differently
did you see hear the chicken noises oh
do yeah there was like straight up
chicken noises happening when I was
playing it like somebody would see me
and then go B and then like not move
like they were like like it was like
Noob mode it was like a [__]
humiliating this whole base I've just
walked
around all right I'm I'm calling up my
boy that H Survivor go we need him to
tell us where Target is I need the me I
need the [__] Survivor to tell us God
when where is
he Soviet Soldier don't tell me I need
to find out where that [__] Target is
cuz I think I left that Target back at
the bloody Mountain relay
base oh [__] did that guy get
up all units stay on guard
he's a chicken on the Run who's stealing
all the re materials so he can upgrade
his SE Shell's base which by the way is
a
16-hour plane flight away but we seem to
be able to do it in a helicopter pretty
quickly it's really pretty there it's
really have you been the SE shells no
it's nice yeah it's supposed to be
beautiful it's supposed to be [__]
idyllic I can never convince a woman to
Mar me I'll take her there go to the SE
shells that'd be a great honeymoon
better in Afghanistan I with a chicken
hat I mean it's probably cheaper to go
to the SE shells in Afghanistan as well
safer too much
safer is they're all [__] waking up
this is the problem all these guys like
knocked over they're all getting waken
up so the problem is it this this jerk
off the honeybee is in here somewhere
apparently I need to know where the hell
it
is because of this prisoner but the
prisoner was back
here at the mountain relay base now I'm
now I've suddenly realized that it's 2:
in the morning now my brain is going
crazy
and what's that gunship great it's in
here somewhere I just don't know exactly
where and there's a car which is pretty
useless then there's these guys and I
kind of feel like I should just go
around and kill them
all this higgledy piggledy map isn't
really helping me at all I can do this
and stick it on my little wrist like a
[__] iPad but that's not really
helping
either
and there's that diamond see the
diamond need that diamond I don't even
care about these guys anymore just going
to throw a grenade at this guy look
that's how past this I
am I can't even [__] throw you can't
even get the distance on get AR can't
get
that what is a chicken supposed to do if
you
can't just di my ass down here great
yeah great [__] wonderful hey quit
kiding
around oh [__] [__] well I guess we know
what the fall damage is
now
everybody Ste assist you need to retri
the new US military weapon known as the
where do be sleep you know what I would
love to
know on
your this game's all right Ty no it's
fun man it's pretty great that intro is
amazing that opening with the unicorn
horn the [__] flaming whale was a
real situation when I started the intro
look at these jerks they're just walking
around in a in a trio kind of drugs do
you think coima takes yeah coima takes a
lot of drugs I thought there some good
[__] there's a
dude you know what I should do I should
book it into that 4x4 and just start
driving around like a mental patient
just for the [__] of it all right that's
what I'm going to
do what's that [__] life ending
[__]
eat
it I'm a
chicken oh the guy saw me
oops do you hear that
sound you hear that
sound oh [__] don't Fon it get get in
the [__] thing wait you can actually
really do that yeah but I don't have
enough like Fon power to do it okay
Jesus Christ I'm TR on Life vision
goggles turn off my
headlamps I'm calling Miller need
Survivor go I need advice Miller tell us
where the damn
is I just yeah I want to see how
resilient this car
is look at this
guy [__] what does or1 do
what there you go that'll do
it I don't know why it said R1 R1 isn't
doing it it's got a
binocular oh [__] there's
a he stopped because it's in
[__] it's in chicken
mode I'm not wearing a chicken hat
anymore so I don't know why it's still
in chicken
mode I'll send your back up I'll knock
those guys down
too this uh this stre is descend into
chaos
Ty it's almost here we go here's a ramp
nope that's a
wall all right I don't need that car
anymore all I got to do is find the
weapons crate it's like not that it's
like a standard weapons
crate right can't be I know like I got
to find the dude who's going to let me
that let me know where it is sure
again what was that I can get this
poster come on some of this must be is
that
diamond rough diamonds man oh look at
all these rough
diamonds weapons
CR here weap
great
guy in there is shocked he's wondering
what the [__] going
on oh yep icing you fools boom
boom just turned your bloody into bloody
mulch watch my heroism go down I do that
too by the way is that bad apparently
really people don't like
it it's against the Geneva Convention
tie
oh
bam oh yeah it's a really satisfying
click they do there o plus 300 herois in
that time boss you need to secure that
prisoner what prisoner the honey
is keeps talking about the prisoner as
if he is on my [__]
[Music]
map took me a long time to figure how to
call my horse I kept double clicking the
left button you kept trying to hit it
like roach you trying to click that
roach button where are you come to me
roach my
goodness were those guys escorting The
Prisoner
because hey prisoner if you're a
prisoner let yourself be known to me I
know I'm covered in Lo and I was wearing
a chicken hat earlier but I swear I'm a
good
dude this is like a genuine frustration
of M now though I can't see where the
[__] thing
is I mean go to
[Music]
missions that's the honey be storage
case sure is we don't know the specifics
but a homing weapon in a case that size
is probably a portable missile recently
the Soviets have lost multip I don't
care anym stop telling
me it's like all around in
here he's in here
somewhere he's in this Maze of tunnels
somewhere no wonder they didn't find Bin
Laden for [__] 10 years you bin lad
do you I don't know probably it's a
coima game you probably did put Bin
Laden in
here that's true actually probably meet
him and give him weapons to fight
Russian made him into the man he was uh
where are we
at anyone here hey PR is like that level
from Aladdin on
Genesis H A Whole New World exactly it's
a whole new world K Kima whole new world
coming to
PS4 look at this [__] look at all
the hey who was the who is Human Torch
Johnny storm in the beginning of the
game yeah that was weird yeah that
that's the [__] main sort of bad guy
or the initial bad guy from the start of
Snake Eater did you ever play Snake
Eater no all right so he's like the
first one that's it well you meet him
the first time you meet him is on the
bridge when him and a man made of bees
attack you from a hel well he the be man
attacks you from a helicopter the boss
is also there who's a lady who you kill
at the end of that game K her the game
yeah that guy is the other dude he's all
electrically play me and
shitzy there's a mortar there's another
Diamond so many diamonds I have so many
diamonds that I'm like frustrated now
that I can't just
like look at this [__] yeah I'm going to
fult in this guy I don't care
anymore I have so many diamonds that
it's like immensely frustrating to me
that I can't just finish this level and
get out with all my [__]
diamonds
I got to find this prisoner man I got to
find this
prisoner there INT in
there oh my God hone has got to be
somewhere in that Fort but the search
area is too wide too wide we need
something to point us in the right
direction something like some sort of
prisoner H has got to be somewhere in
that Fort H has got to be somewhere in
that fort with the search area is too
wide we need something to point us in
the right
direction make this easy I don't know
maybe they did make it easy and my like
24 hours awake mind just can't deal with
it right
now I can't tell anymore look at that
guy that guy's just been these guys just
walked in like what the [__] is going on
oh look at all these just
respawned [__] it I'm going back into
the for Fort it looks like the Indiana J
like Last Crusade Temple pretty cool
right all right it must be in here has
to be in here yeah so all we're going to
do is go
in find bin ladden and get out
interrogate a soldier that's not a bad
of except the last one I interrogated
didn't tell me dick and then I to murder
him feel like I I got higher look at all
these [__] diamonds how diamonds just
lying around the
place like did these Afghans or Russians
who were like living here not figure out
got to find
diamonds there's another Diamond over
there look at them [__]
everywhere oh I'm going to kill myself
again if I jump down there
though no diamonds worth that no
Diamond's worth a human life tie that
maybe a really big diamond and a
particularly useless human life
mhm like an Indiana Jones my way across
there actually
no
up that's climbing up entering alert
status oh [__] you're okay he's all
right sick
recovery it's like every 5 minutes a
bunch of them wake up again and start
like like what the
[__]
oh Sandstorm Darude is
happening oh there it is I got the
diamond all is
well got have so many diamonds right now
I just want to dump them into my base
before the game saves
again maybe it's downstairs maybe it's
down here maybe it's down here in this
tunnel
hello hello must be down here look at
this
[__] look at this idilic [__] I don't
know how I'm supposed to Fon it out of
here
though oh I [__] got it I'm in here
it's in here somewhere sun will rise
momentarily Sunrise
imminent doesn't matter I'm in a [__]
cave all right nvgs he
says
why would night vision goggles
help the man said use night vision
goggles there might be Clues to the
target's location at that Outpost take a
look
around 6:00 a.m. in the game new guards
will appear good point darkland
you need to retrieve the new US military
weapon known as the honey it should be
hidden somewhere in for there's a photo
of the honey be on
yourid oh
honeybee
nope that's not what I was going
for there we
go it's going to bring me back out
again where am
I yep that's not where I want to
be
My worry is if it's in here then how
I I got to get it out of
here that's the way I came in
right how far back am I here no I came
in over that side actually maybe it's up
here oh hello
H honey
be
oh
hello look at this sneaking
Mission all
right no for a second I thought that was
it all right let me choke this guy and
see if I can get
some info out of
them
where's the honeybee
[__] making sure I don't walk
past it here what the [__] is this kind
God damn
it I crawl my ass out of here
again hey go dive through the
hole I'm beyond diamonds
I've gone past the point of
diamonds all I want is the honey
bee my life will not be
complete let that sweet sweet honey what
is he even doing he's
just well that's that
okay I'll find someone to
interrogate problem is I don't have any
goddamn
ah too many of these [__]
around from all over the
place so many soldiers not even one
honeybee not even
one not even a single
one how do I only have one weapon like
how good can a rocket launcher B give me
that
diamond give me that
diamond I wake this [__] up with some
like bat
salt going knock all these bottles of
wine over I'll make me feel better is
that
it that looks like it could be it
no when I got down here he said put your
night vision goggles
on made me feel so hopeful that I was
almost
there yet nothing Apparently one of the
Fighters survived you might know where
the honeybee has been stashed but he's
probably already in Soviet
hands he is that's true that's why I
can't find him
anywhere what is that
metal feel like we've been on this level
for
12 hours now search to the cave search
the room here the honeybee is in there
God not the base not the
Bas killing me won't bring back your
goddamn honeyed Mar marker removed look
how many markers you can do remed Marker
removed too many
markers everyone reckons it's in here
just dive my ass
in
who would have thought they' hide it
there what where did they [__] hide
it that it's stuck in the [__]
wall oh my
God
honeybee you SEC the target oh thank
Christ for
thato
yourr to use the honey the order was to
recover it with it
ammunition great I can't use it
wonderful oh thank you chat
mucho
oato appreciate it now I got to get my
ass out of this situation with this
honey badger be
thing how big is the
Zone Escape VI a
chopper with the
honeybee get to the
chopper I mean I drive my ass out can I
drive my ass out maybe I can drive my
ass out all right let's
try if I can find my way out of here
again
unbelievable thank you so much it's
almost 3:00 a.m. here I'm losing my mind
I wouldn't have been able to do it
without your
help I needed to at least finish this
Mission before getting my ass home
taking that that
long ride back out to Oakland what the
[__] what the [__]
what is this
[__] better not be those dudes
again he said I wasn't to use the
honeybee not even if the skulls turned
up oh [__]
mantis that's a
surprising reaction to what just
happened
who
okay
what's going on here is [__] anyone's
guys does a robot have
me
skull
face you look well rested Big
Boss my my how you've
changed you became a demon for such
little weapons as was
that well I'm sure you'll see the bigger
picture
eventually your face is slightly
different than last
time he's all Whited up like he's in Mad
Max now if you get out of here alive
witness me
rest in peace this
time I'll see you in
hell
boss
uh where is he [__] shoot
him don't know his robot pallet just
picked him up ah I forgot what they're
called what's he doing to that
Soldier oh [__]
this
everywhere those skulls are too fast a
Hing weapon boss maybe it's time to see
what yeah [__]
think
no not
distance don't want to hit don't want to
H Too Close
[__] yeah that's what's going
on holy [__] they're fast all
right
didn't exactly do much damage did
it we can forget about that bonus now
yeah just a
bit only got four rounds left on the
thing oh [__] should I actually be
trying to kill these guys or should be
getting the [__] out of
here
[__] maybe I just have to oh
[__] like do I just have to kill these
gen pop
guys holy
[__] how we looking all right you know
what oh
[__] go go go go go go go go go
go go nope NOP bad idea bad idea
this is that fight ORF flight thing I'm
not sure which one I should be
doing yeah definitely not
that God damn it all right first boss
fight of the game I guess got to hit him
snake talk to me snake
wanted to see just how much player
agency was in
there guess a boss fight's a boss
fight
everywhere a chicken [__] fantastic
those skulls are too fast aing weapon
boss maybe it's time to see what the
honey
do
now we're
talking we that
bonus all right that was one of them
dead one of them
dead no I'm can't fating
you
ooh
poster come on
[__] [__]
man
got keep
moving keep moving till our fog goes
down I
guess
[__] I got Splash damage on that
one
[__] all right these things aren't as
hard obviously it's on [__] baby mode
if this wasn't the end of a 6-hour
stream I'd probably
let's just say I'm going to replay this
Mission when we're done here come
on I don't have anything to
do [__] hell even on baby mode get to
the car and drive away well I tried to
get out of there but they all basically
covered the exit and
then shot me straight away so that's
that's going to happen every time I'm
guessing all right I got it this
time
those skulls are too
fast that
[__] now we're
talking we can forget about that bonus
now
actually don't even need to uh Target
them just hit the
[__]
all right one more
storm one more
storm
ah so I think I killed one of them with
that melee strike on a went or
two God my hands are so sweaty
I'm trying to remember on the map where
the open area is I think it's
here
[__] come
on
[__] holy
[__]
you took down the skulls boss [__] you
really are a living legend all
right Bry back to base I bring your
stupid honey be back to base I killed
some of these [__] is that the last
one or is he dead
holy
[__] oh my
goodness I'm sorry you all had to
witness that that was embarrassing for
everyone involved mostly me these are
all [__] dead God damn
it I Fon all of you and you will speak
nothing of the chicken hat that you saw
here nothing don't even mention
it thank you for all the congratulations
I don't feel I deserve it
much obliged though I very much
appreciate
it oh my
God L all right where's the [__]
limaa so I can get my ass out of here
where is it over there damn all right
let's try to car let's try to car a good
suggestion earlier stand hopefully I
haven't beached it support helicopter
has
arrived woo
all right it's me and my chicken hat
yeah oh
[__]
yeah
oops this thing handles like a son of a
[__] all right where's that gunship I
don't want to run into
him
arrived at base there must be more of
those skull guys right I can't just say
that was
it it's also great that the entire point
of this mission is basically null and
void CU I just used all the
rocket but hey what you got to
do I guess I didn't need to I guess I
could have just like used my weapon I
was probably a another way winning
the winning the
mission I I guess I could stealth my ass
through here but God knows that I don't
want to
bother is there anyone
here yeah look at these
guys oh hey
dudes what's up hey don't worry about me
I'm just driving
through just driving
through I love how it does the zoom
thing for every single person like
really we're good don't worry about it
Lads don't worry I'm I'm just driving
through passing
by chicken hat don't worry about
it right get in time to go I'm
in got to pick this plant before I
go
yeah get the [__] out of
here
woo yeah good point I probably should
have used the mvgs like I was doing in
the last
last goddamn firefight I was in what are
you going to
do chicken hat extraction arrived at M
base beekeeper take that Nicholas
Cage development project has been added
look at all that stuff I just
unlocked
unbelievable What a Beautiful Day great
work D B really code name chicken fair
enough get all that [__] love that
[__] all that heroism roll credits let's
we're going to roll credits on this live
stream oh my goodness I'm back on camera
after all
that miger solid five the phantom pain
there you go folks 6 hours worth of it
right there on gamespot.com
youtube.com/ Gamespot hey if you're
watching on gaming what's going on shut
up shut up talking I've been listening
to your [__] all day
godamn offs slot if you're watching this
on gaming.
youtube.com/ Gamespot hit that ad button
if you're watching on Twitch and I'll
follow if you're watching on Gamespot
hey we're done that was the first six
hours of melar solid five the phantom
pain thank you for putting up on my
[__] it's 3:00 a.m. in the morning
here in the uh west coast of America
Good Morning Europe I hope you're
enjoying the game uh good morning rest
of the world or afternoon good evening
good night um hope enjoy the game it was
pretty good I like it it's 10 out of 10
on Gamespot our review is up our video
review should be up Ty is there some hot
PC gameplay up yet uh no no no but soon
or sometime YouTu processing it might
take a while YouTube's processing it's
their [__] fault it might be a ball
but make sure you check out gamespot's
channel over there uh to check that out
as well and we are done thank you so
much for hanging out really appreciate
it sorry I sucked it's been a long day
um thanks for hanging out thanks to Eric
Tay Round of Applause for staying L
smallest Round of Applause you're ever
going to get this entire building is
empty H and of course Ty rude as well
for uh for hanging out and doing all
that hot work uh I will be back tomorrow
today technically 2 p p.m. Pacific in
about 11 hours for the lobby on YouTube
twitch and Gamespot so uh check it out
then if you have any questions about the
fan and Pain by all means ask me um on
Twitter Dano dwire uh but uh apart from
that I'm done thanks so much and I'll
see you guys
[Music]
guys